HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
TODAY WE HAVE THIRTY THREE BILLS
ON THE AGENDA.
HOWEVER PLEASE KNOW THAT AB FIVE
THREE SIX AND A. B. EIGHT ONE
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA.
SO WE WILL BE HEARING A TOTAL OF
THIRTY ONE BILLS TODAY WITH
SIXTEEN OF THOSE BILLS ON
CONSENT.
AS A REMINDER WE LIMITED
TESTIMONY TO TO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
MAY ADD ON BY STATING THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
BERMAN WILL BE SUBSTITUTING FOR
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
ON OUR COMMITTEE AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
FOR JOINING US WHEN HE DOES JOIN
US.
WE DON'T YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT
WE WILL BE -- STARTING TODAY'S
HEARING AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO CALL UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA.
YOUR LAST ON THE LIST BUT FIRST.
I'LL BE FIRST.
OF AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR IS A LONG
OVERDUE BILL THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THIS LEGISLATURE ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
BACK IS THE THIRD YEAR.
OF THAT I'M INTRODUCING THIS
BILL AND IF YOU'RE DOING THE
MATH I'VE BEEN HERE NOW FOR MY
IS MY THIRD YEAR SO IT'S
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
AND SO MANY OTHERS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE ALL WATCHED THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN FINANCIAL CRISIS PLUNGED
OUR STATE INTO THE GREAT
RECESSION HAVE PRECIPITATED
DEVASTATING CUTS OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL SECURITY
INSURANCE STATE SUPPLEMENTARY
PAYMENT PROGRAM.
SS I SS BE GRANTS OF THE SOLE
SOURCE OF INCOME FOR ONE POINT
THREE MILLION LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IT HELPS THESE INDIVIDUALS PAY
RENT BUY FOOD PAPER UTILITIES
PAY FOR MEDICINE AND OTHER BASIC
NECESSITIES.
AT ITS PUREST THE SS I SS P.
PROGRAM IS A DEFINING COMPONENT
OF OUR STATES SOCIAL SAFETY NET.
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND NINE IN
AN EFFORT TO CLOSE UNPRECEDENTED
BUDGET DEFICITS THE STATE REDUCE
TO REDUCE ITS PORTION OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SOCIETY AS A
SPEAK GRANT.
AFTER REPEATED CUTS SS I SS BE
GRANTS ARE CURRENTLY AT NINE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE DOLLARS PER
MONTH ON THE 88% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
A LESS THAN THE AMOUNT PROVIDED
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE FOR THE
CUTS.
IN MANY COUNTIES THE COST OF
LIVING FOR A STUDIO APARTMENT
FAR EXCEEDS THE TOTAL SSI AS A
SPEAK GRANT PROVIDED.
AND BEAR MARKET WHEN EXCEEDS 50%
THE MAXIM SS I SS BE GRANT FOR
INDIVIDUAL IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
AS A RESULT SS I SS P.
RECIPIENTS BEEN FORCED INTO
POVERTY BECOMING HOMELESS GOING
HUNGRY OR FACING SEVERE PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH CRISES.
WE ARE NOW PROJECTED TO HAVE A
BUDGET SURPLUS OF APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS.
YOU MUST TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO RESTORE THE CUTS MADE A
DECADE AGO TO THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM AND KEEPING IN MIND THAT.
OVER. TEN YEARS OF THESE CUTS
LITERALLY THOSE THAT HAVE THE
LEAST ABILITY TO AFFORD IT.
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF SAVINGS -- OVER TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I THINK
IT'S TIME THAT WE PAY THEM BACK.
I AM NOT EVEN PAY THE BACK IN
TERMS OF SOMETHING THAT'S OWED
TO THEM BUT REALLY -- IT'S IT'S
PAYING BACK OURSELVES IN TERMS
OF MAINTAIN THE TO THE DIGNITY
OF THOSE LIVING IN POVERTY IN
OUR STATE.
AB FORTY THIRTY FOUR WILL HELP
PROTECT THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE RIGHT TO
LIVE IN DIGNITY NOT POVERTY.
WITH THE TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY AS CARTER POWER BAGS
IN A LOCK DOWN NATION OF SILICON
VALLEY.
AND CHRISTIE'S TO POVERTY --
BURCHETT OF EDUCATE ADVOCATE.
BEFORE OUR NEXT WITNESS I WOULD
LIKE TO ESTABLISH COR.
RAMOS HERE MATHIS [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A CORE
[inaudible]
YOUR NEXT.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME'S CARTER POWERS
BANKS AND I'M WITH THE LAW
FOUNDATION OF SILICON VALLEY THE
LAW FOUNDATION -- WE ADVANCE THE
RIGHTS OF THE UNDER REPRESENTED
IN SILICON VALLEY -- THROUGH A
EDUCATION ADVOCACY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FREE LEGAL SERVICES --
PERSONALLY -- I'M AN ECONOMIC
RIGHTS ADVOCATE.
THAT MEANS I'M DEALING DAILY
WITH PUBLIC PUBLIC BENEFITS
ISSUES AND I'M FIGHTING DAILY
FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT OUR
CLIENTS NEED IN ORDER TO LIVE A
HEALTHY LIFE -- AS A RESULT WE
ARE INCREDIBLY EXCITED AND
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE OF
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR AND SO
GRATEFUL -- FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AS SUPPORT OF THESE ISSUES --
AS WELL AS OUR AREA. HUNDRED
DOLLARS IS SO MUCH MORE THAN
JUST ABOUT A NUMBER FOR MY
CLIENTS IT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING ABLE TO AFFORD.
COUGH AND COLD MEDICINE -- THAT
DOESN'T LEAD TO AN EMERGENCY
ROOM VISIT IN THE FUTURE WHEN
THAT COUGH IT DOESN'T GET BETTER.
WITH THE DIFFERENCE BEING ABLE
TO BE MOVED OUT OF BED BUG
INFESTED ROOMS AND THAT PATH OFF
THE STREETS.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HEAT
ELECTRICITY AND VIABLE CLOTHING.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT AND WE TAKE
SO MUCH FOR GRANTED THAT WE GET
TO JUST GET FAT AND THEY HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THOSE TWO THINGS.
AND THOSE SHORT TERM HEALTH
OUTCOMES LEAD TO LONG TERM
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
HELP IN THE SHORT TERM THE LONG
TERM.
THAT'S WHERE WE GET THESE
MASSIVE BURDENS -- ON AND OTHER
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS [inaudible]
AS WELL.
PERSONALLY -- MY CLIENT WILL
TRAVEL OVER THREE HOURS THERE
AND BACK ON BUS JUST TO TALK TO
ME. TO HELP.
CHANGE THEIR BENEFIT AMOUNTS BY
TEN OR FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
THIS A HUNDRED DOLLARS WOULD BE
INCREDIBLE FOR MY CLIENTS AND
FOR SSI RECIPIENTS AROUND
CALIFORNIA -- AND AS A RESULT I
STRONGLY URGE -- EVERYONE ON
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND INVESTED NOT ONLY.
A HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA BUT A
MORE STABLE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON AT THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
CHRISTIE'S PUBLIC BURCHETT FROM
EDUCATE ADVOCATE.
LEISTER FAMILIES OF CHILDREN
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND ARE BASED
IN YOUR DISTRICT MADAM CHAIR.
I'M RAISING CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS WHO ARE ON SOCIAL
SECURITY AT THE COSTLY ENDEAVOR.
AND WE CERTAINLY NEED TO BRING
ASSETS THAT I UP TO THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL TO ASSIST THE
FAMILIES WE SERVE AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARS BILL.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR AND WE
HOPE FOR YOUR I'VE LET VOTE.
THANK YOU IN FACT THANK YOU FOR
COMING UP FROM.
I EIGHTY YES.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WHO STEP UP TO THE MIKE GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE?
CAPTAIN OF THE OLDEST CALIFORNIA
WILL PROVIDE SECOND EDITION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YEP BUT YOU GO IN FIRST.
BOB SHARI SHE'D AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WOOD OKAY [inaudible]
GOING BACK [inaudible]
NO.
HERE SINKING IN BY.
MY NAME'S JEFF STARTED YEAR AN
APPLICANT.
I REPRESENT.
CARA I REPRESENT HOW I REPRESENT
DOG FIGHT.
I REPRESENT A NUMBER OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND I BROUGHT A
FEW FRIENDS.
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT I AM
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR BRINGING YOUR FRIENDS.
BACK AT KRAMER MATTER ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RUSSELL RAWLINGS RICK --
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS FOR
SSI AND DISABILITY ACTION
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU
.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER FROM SAN DIEGO
I'M WITH EMPOWER FAMILY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M A SPECIAL
NEEDS PARALEGAL INFIRM SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RICKROLLING
DRIPSEY HARKIS SO SHE'S A
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES -- IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RON MACINTOSH I'M A
SENIOR ADVOCATE FOR SAINT MARY'S
CENTER AND WAS TALKING
CALIFORNIA HAVE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT COOPER I
REPRESENT DOG FIGHT WAS THIS
BILL IF YOU READ SCRIPTURE
AFFECT ME IN A SECOND HOMES
ORGANIZED COMMUNITY STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A MERRY NATION'S PATHWAYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND BRADLEY PART OF SAINT MERRI
CENTER HOPE AND JUSTICE AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TERRY JOE TENNIS CONTRA COSTA IN
SOLANO COUNTY FOOD BANK IN THE
ANTIOCH SENIOR CENTER I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT WE NEED IT.
THANK YOU.
CHANTE PRASAD ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK AND
CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SECRET PEOPLE'S
AMONG THE COUNCIL LEADERSHIP
BOARD WITH THE POLICY IS BY
ASIAN LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION I'M ALSO SS I
RECIPIENTS AND I'M ONE HUNDRED
AND 9% OF IT.
THANK YOU AND HAVE A BLAST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PERCY JACKSON
OFFICE SAY MERS.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME'S KERRY WHY SADDAM
I HAVEN'T GIVEN UP HOPE OF
JUSTICE WAS SAYING THERE'S SOME
A SS I SS BE RECIPIENT I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ENTER SHANE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS REPRESENTING FOR
BANKS FOR ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MADAM CHAIR MICRO
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU COULD HAVE DONE A
FROM UP HERE.
YOUR AVAILABLE YOU WOULD HAVE
BEEN OKAY UP HERE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO BE
FRIENDLY AND DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE THINK THE AUTHOR
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MOLLY BYNUM UW OUTS MILITARY AND
THIRTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ADRIAN IDEAS AND I'M A AS A SIZE
RECIPIENT AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARIA DOOR GODI I AM A YEAH.
PARENT ADVOCATE FOR SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILD I AM ALSO.
HE IS THE SSI RECIPIENT NYMAN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SABRINA CHRIS SAID HE
WOULD LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRE IS
THE CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI AM ANGEL HICKSON AND I AM A
PARENT ADVOCATE AND I'M ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YEAH HI AM JENNIFER CARPENTER
I'M A PARENT OF A SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILD WHO RECEIVES AS A SIGN OF
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M NICOLE NEVER BACK UNTIL I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT I AM A
PARENT OF A SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD
THINK.
THANK YOU.
HI AM MILLION BUCKS FROM THE
FOOD BANK OF CONTRA COSTA AND
SOLANO AND STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY CENTER L<c.cyan>G WITH THE</c>
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M DEBBIE TOTH WITH TRACE AN
AGING NONPROFIT SERVING FRAIL
ELDERS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND CONTRA COSTA
SOLANO NAPA IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
Q..
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
EARLY FINKEL WITH THE FOOD BANK
OF CONTRA COSTA IN SOLANO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU WE HAVE
TWO MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING
THEY'RE MAKING THE RENTAL WAIT
FOR THEM.
ELLA JONES I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
THE FOOD BANK AND ADVOCATE AND
AMOUNTS OF STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU PLEASE VOTE.
FOR THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M STRONG SUPPORT SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AS WELL AND I'M MY
NAME IS ANN RUSSELL I AM ALSO A
STUDENT AT CONTRA COSTA.
AT COLLEGE.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
STERN MATHIS ASSEMBLYMAN DEVON
MATHIS NAMAN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR.
IF THAT BE ALRIGHT WITH YES THAT
SOUNDS WONDERFUL MISTER KALRA --
GREAT BILL LOVE THE EFFORT AND I
JUST WANT TO REALLY SHOW STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE WAVE
OF THE FIRST.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IS PROBABLY THE
FIRST BEFORE I HAD -- REPUBLICAN
MAKE THE MOTION AND SECOND.
AND I THINK THAT SPEAKS -- BUT
SPEAKS TO THE BIPARTISAN NATURE
THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
OF I HAVE SOME OTHER GOOD BILLS
FOR YOU TO ALL OF US IN LATER.
BUT YOU KNOW WE WE GOT THIS
REALLY IS A BI PARTISANSHIP
ABOUT DIGNITY -- WE'D BE NOT
ONLY SAW A NUMBER OF REALLY
WONDERFUL CARE PROVIDERS.
BUT A NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS THESE
ARE REAL PEOPLE THAT THAT REALLY
SACRIFICE SO THAT WE CAN GET
THROUGH TOUGH BUDGETARY TIMES OF
STATE I THINK IT'S TIME WE MADE
THEM ALL TO THE BEST BY ABILITY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A FIRST BY DOCTOR CHOICE
SECOND BY MISTER MATHIS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RAMOS
HI RAMOS AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE BERMAN.
CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
STONE HI.
THE CURRENT VOTE ON YOUR BILL IS
FIVE TWO ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
PROMOTION SECOND -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR RAMOS I
RESIGNED MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
STONE AYE.
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS FOR WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MR COOLEY ON AB YOU.
ONE ZERO SIX EIGHT ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR VERY GOOD.
I'LL MAKE THIS BRIEF I HAVE AN
OBLIGATION THE CHAMBERS IN A FEW
MINUTES -- YEAH THIS BILL JUST
CARRIES ON THE OUTSTANDING WORK
OF THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
PROVIDED FEW OTHER PIECES
CONFIDENTIALITY AND SOME TEAM
PARTNERS. TO SUPPORT THAT WORK
IT'S A VERY GOOD BILL.
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY --
JULIE MCCORMACK FROM THE SOURCE
LAWCENTER SUPPORT [inaudible]
AND OTHERS.
JUL ASK YOU TO JUMP IN.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ALREADY.
A PALE SO SHORT THAT.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR VICE CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY FOR
AUTHORING MAYBE.
TEN SIXTY EIGHT I'M AT THE
ASSEMBLY WERE MENTIONED I'M
JULIE MCCORMICK AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
CALIFORNIANS SPONSOR.
OF AB TEN SIXTY EIGHT CLC
REPRESENTS A PROXY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND CHILDREN UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE DEPENDENCY
COURT LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
PLASTER COUNTY.
AND WE HAVE SEEN SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CF TEASE
WITHIN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM THAT THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
AND I THINK THOSE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED -- BY THE
AUTHOR -- WE'RE LOOKING -- FOR
YOU KNOW A NEUTRAL FACILITATOR
AS WELL AS EDUCATIONAL RIGHTS
HOLDERS TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. TO ADDRESS
INFORMATION SHARING REQUIREMENTS
AS WELL AS PROPER NOTICE TO BE
GIVEN -- SO WE ARE HERE AS
SPONSORS AND IN STRONG FOR
SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR IBM
THANK YOU AND I DO.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I
DO WANT TO KNOW THANK YOU RECORD
I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE.
WHEN I APOLOGIZE WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE PRETTY GOLDBERG SHE IS
A RESOURCE PARENT VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THIS THE UP TO PROCESS AND
SHIP LIKE TO SHARE?
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SEEING ME TODAY MY NAME IS
FOR THE GOLD BURKE I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I AM THE
RESOURCE PARENT TO MY TWO YEAR
OLD GRANDSON
I HAVE PARTICIPATED IN MANY
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM MEETINGS
AND I BELIEVE THE CHANGES
OFFERED BY A. B..
TEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT CARE GIVERS AND CHILDREN
ARE TRULY HEARD IN THESE
MEETINGS.
FIRST I THINK HAVING A NEUTRAL
FACILITATOR. FOR THESE MEETINGS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT THE SECOND
SOCIAL WORKER ASSIGNED TO MY
GRANDSONS CASE FACILITATED A
CHILD A FAMILY TEAM MEETINGS.
THIS DID NOT ALLOW FOR OPEN
CONVERSATION BECAUSE OF OUR PRE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIP AND THE
IMPRESSION OF THE SOCIAL WORKER
IMPACTED OF OUR LEVEL OF COMFORT
TO BE ENGAGED DURING THESE
MEETINGS.
WE FELT THAT THE OUTCOME OF
THESE MEETINGS WERE ALREADY PRE
DETERMINED BY HER.
WITH THE HELP OF MY CARE GIVER
ADVOCATE WE WERE ABLE TO ASK FOR
SUPPORTS LIKE FINANCIAL HELP
FOOD STAMPS AND GAS CARDS
HOWEVER SHE WAS ALWAYS QUICK TO
SAY THAT SHE COULD NOT ASSIST
WITH THESE REQUESTS.
WE NEVER RECEIVED ANY OF THE
SUPPORTS OUR SERVICES WE ASK FOR
AND FELT LIKE NOTHING WAS
ACCOMPLISHED IN THESE MEETINGS.
I ALSO BELIEVE IN THE PROVISION
IN AB TEN SIXTY EIGHT TO PROVIDE
FAMILIES WITH SUFFICIENT NOTICE
BEFORE CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM
MEETING IS CRITICAL.
WE NEVER RECEIVED ADVANCE NOTICE
OF THE MEETINGS THE MOST NOTICE
I RECEIVED WITH LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AND THEREFORE I HAD
TO MAKE MIGHT REARRANGE MY
SCHEDULE SCRAMBLE TO GET THINGS
DONE.
MAKE SURE MY GRANDSON WAS TAKEN
CARE OF OR BE LATE TO OTHER
MEETINGS AND COMMITMENTS THAT I
HAD ALREADY ON MY CALENDAR.
IT WAS VERY STRESSFUL AND VERY
BURDENSOME.
MY FAMILY AND I ARE NOT THE
EXCEPTION I HAVE TALKED AND
WORKED WITH OTHER GRANDPARENTS
THROUGH AN ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS
THE ALLIANCE FOR RELATIVE CARE
GIVERS.
AND THEY SHARE THE SAME
EXPERIENCES THAT I HAVE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE PROPER NOTICE
AND BETTER FOR THOSE
FACILITATION OF CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAM MEETINGS WHICH IS WHY I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND A VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
CHANTIERS RUN WHAT THE ALLIES
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS WERE VERY
HAPPY TO BE COSPONSORED OF THIS
BILL AS WELL AND OF COURSE OUR
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GEN REX ROAD WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WESLEY SEVERAL JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH SPORT.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE THE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
VERY GOOD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER CONGRESSIONAL VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THIS AFTERNOON.
Q..
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
GIBSON SECOND BY MISTER STONE
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES I REYES AYE
MATHIS.
BERMAN CHOI FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
STONE AYE.
KERN VOTE IS.
THREE I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU.
MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT [inaudible]
THE SHE GETS AND YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING ON ITEM.
NUMBER THIRTY AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
LEVINE.
SEKARANG THAT IS CORRECT THANK
YOU.
AND IS WAITING FOR MY HELP TO
SHOW OKAY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
CONTRACT WITH A NON PROFIT LEGAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATION. TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE.
WHAT CALIFORNIA ALREADY A
REQUIRES THAT ON A COMPANY AND
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS WHO ARE
TRANSFERRED TO THE CUTS THE
OFFICE OF THE REFUGE ARE
RESETTLEMENT -- BE PROVIDED WITH
A LEGAL SERVICE THIS PROTECTION
DOES NOT EXTEND TO UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN.
WHO ARE TRANSFERRED TO THE
CALIFORNIA FOSTER YOUTH SYSTEM?
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT ON THAT
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE SYSTEMS
ARE.
PROVIDED WITH ESSENTIAL
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICE
NECESSARY TO SEEK LAWFUL --
RESIDENCY IN THE UNITED STATES
HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY BUT THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR IS A REPRESENT THE EXACT
DIRECTOR OF THE LEGAL SERVICES
OF CALIFORNIA LEGAL SERVICES.
FOR CHILDREN WHOSE SELF
INTRODUCE.
SORRY ACTUALLY I THINK I'LL TELL
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
LEGAL SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
BUT I AM ODESSA VERY POWERS
SOMEONE IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY
WITH THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA WE WELCOME YOU WOULD
YOU BRING THAT.
THE MICROPHONE CLOSE SHE THANK
PASSIVELY.
SO WHAT THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THOUSAND
YOUTH UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF
THE DEPENDENCY COURT IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
WE THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
FOR AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
GIPSON FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVINGS
BEHALF.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE BY ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDED WITH LEGAL IMMIGRATION
SERVICE AS WELL MOST
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN FOSTER
CARE QUALIFY FOR IMMIGRATION
RELIEF.
THAT RELIEF IS DIFFICULT TO
OBTAIN IT WITHOUT LEGAL
ASSISTANCE ESPECIALLY IN TODAY'S
POLITICAL CLIMATE.
SPECIAL MCCANN JUVENILE STATUS
WHICH IS ALSO CALLED SUGGESTS
WAS ENACTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HELP ABUSED
ABANDONED AND NEGLECTED
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN.
OBTAIN LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENCY IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND IN TURN PROVIDE GREATER
STABILITY FOR THESE YOUNG PEOPLE.
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN WHO LEAVE
FOSTER CARE WITHOUT OBTAINING
SUGGESTS OR OTHER FORMS OF AND
IMMIGRATION RELIEF.
WILL BE UNABLE TO WORK AND TO
TRANSITION TO SUCCESSFUL
ADULTHOOD.
HOWEVER THERE IS NO MECHANISM TO
ENSURE THAT UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE RECEIVE
THE LEGAL ASSISTANCE NECESSARY
TO OBTAIN IMMIGRATION RELIEF.
AS A RESULT THE LEVEL OF
ASSISTANCE THAT THE YOUTH GETS
ON THERE IMMIGRATION MATTER
VARIES FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY.
FOR EXAMPLE IN COUNTY SUCH AS
SACRAMENTO OUR LAWYERS HAVE TO
SCRAMBLE TO GET AN IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY OR A NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION TO REPRESENT OUR
CLIENT.
AND LOS ANGELES THE CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY WORKS CLOSELY
WITH OUR ATTORNEYS TO IDENTIFY A
LOCAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
AND PRO BONO ATTORNEYS WHO WILL
PROVIDE IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES FOR OUR CLIENTS.
WE HAVE ALSO HEARD STORIES FROM
OTHER COUNTIES.
WHERE NO IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES ARE OBTAINED AND AS A
RESULT THE YOUTH NEVER RECEIVE
THE RELIEF THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED
TO AND EVENTUALLY LEAVE THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WITHOUT
IMMIGRATION STATUS?
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR WILL
PREVENT UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN
FROM LEADING FOSTER CARE WITHOUT
IMMIGRATION RELIEF.
BY REQUIRING NOTICE TO MINORS
COUNCIL WHEN A CHILD OR NON
MINOR DEPENDENT IS UNDOCUMENTED
AND IN NEED OF SUGGEST OR OTHER
IMMIGRATION RELIEF.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR WILL
ALSO CREATE A FUNDING SOURCE
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO CONTRACT WITH NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION AND
ASSISTANCE TO UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN AND NON MINOR
DEPENDENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
JOHN CHILDREN WITH THE ALLIES
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS FOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHAT THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
ABSOLUTELY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
THANK YOU DR EMOTION SO MOVED.
CAN I DO HAVE MOTION BY MISTER
GIBSON SECOND BY MISTER STONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
RIGHT YES.
I REYES I MATHIS [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
AYE GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN STONE
STONE AYE. THREE ZERO WILLIE THE
ROLE OF AN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON
ITEM THIRTY TWO AB FORTINO THREE
ON BEHALF OF MS CARILLO WILL
LOVE TO INDEED.
THANK YOU.
OTHER TEAMS GATHER GATHERING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN OH THREE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN CARILLO--
WHICH WOULD CORRECT THAT
OVERSIGHT IN THE STATE LAW TO
ENSURE THAT DEEPLY IMPOVERISHED
INDIVIDUALS CAN APPLY FOR
CRITICAL RESOURCES WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA AT WORK OPPORTUNITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY. FOR KIDS CAL
WORKS PROGRAMS WAS ENACTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED TO ENSURE
THAT CAL WORKS PARENTS WHO HAVE
TIMED OUT.
OF BUT WE'RE WAS RECEIVING A FOR
THEIR CHILDREN ARE NOT ALSO
RECEIVING GENERAL ASSISTANCE
TODAY THE LAW STATES.
THAT IF A PARENT WHO IS NOT
RECEIVING CAL WORKS WITH
CHILDREN UNDER EIGHTEEN WHO ARE
IN FOSTER CARE.
HAVE DIED FOR A RUN AWAY CANNOT
RECEIVE GENERAL ASSISTANCE AB
FORTINO THREE CORRECTS THE STATE
LAW AND LIMIT GENERAL ASSISTANCE
BEFORE PARENTS WHO IS NOT
RECEIVING CAL WORKS BENEFITS.
IF OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE -- SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN OH THREE
OKAY -- WILL BE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE WESTERN CENTER OF LAW
AND POVERTY IN ADDITION -- TO
COALITION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THEY
WAS SELF INTRODUCE [inaudible]
FIRST WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DESK OF
OUR CLUB IN THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY WE ARE CO
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION --
AS PEOPLE NOTE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IS FIFTY YEARS
OLD THE BILL AT THE CAPITOL FOR
MORE THAN.
FORTY AND WE WERE HERE DURING
WELFARE REFORM -- THIS WELFARE
REFORM WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
WANTED TO SEE HAPPEN BUT WE WERE
DILIGENTLY PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
PROCESS SEES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE LAW THAT WE
ARE.
WORKING TO REFINE NOW -- DEAL
THAT WOULD FIX AN OVERSIGHT.
WHEN WE ESTABLISHED WELFARE TO
WORK AND THE NEW TIME LIMITS WE
SAID THAT PEOPLE SHOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO GET AROUND THE TIME OF
THIS IN THE COLORS PROGRAMS?
BY SIMPLY SANCTIONING OFFER NOT
PARTICIPATING IN WELFARE TO WORK
AND THEN GOING OVER TO THE
GENERAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN
THE COUNTY.
AND IT WAS UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT
WAS THE PURPOSE OF THE LAW THAT
WE HAVE THE WORD BENDING TODAY.
HOWEVER AS THE YEARS GO BY AND
MORE -- PERRANCE A SANCTION OFF
AID BECAUSE OF THE TIME LIMIT.
AND THEN THEY BECOME DESTITUTE
AND WITH ECONOMIC HARDSHIP MANY
OF THEM FALL INTO A SITUATION
WHERE THEY LOSE THEIR CHILDREN
THEY LOSE CUSTODY OF THEIR
CHILDREN OR THEIR CHILDREN FALL
INTO HARD TIMES.
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IN A HALL.
AT REPORT CHILDREN ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE HOSPITALIZED
APPARENTLY SEC AND SO THEY MAY
GO INTO THE HOSPITAL LONG TERM.
AND THEIR PARENT REMAINS AT HOME
WITHOUT A CHILD IN THEIR HOME.
TODAY'S LAW MAKES A PERSON.
WHO THE A SINGLE ADULTS WITHOUT
CHILDREN?
IN ELIGIBLE FOR GENERAL
ASSISTANCE.
IF AT ONE POINT IN THE PAST.
THEY WERE SANCTIONED OFF AID.
EVEN IF THEY HAVEN'T HAD CUSTODY
OF THEIR CHILD FOR YEARS.
EVEN IF THEY'RE TRYING TO RETAIN
CUSTODY OF THEIR CHILDREN HAVING
ACCESS TO GA WOULD HELP THEM TO
DO THAT.
WE THINK THAT'S AN ERROR IN THE
LAW WE WILL WE ARE ASKING
THROUGH THIS BILL THAT IT BE
FIXED -- AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE WAS THE COMMITTEES
RECEIVED A LETTER OF CONCERN
FROM THE COUNTY IS -- AND FROM
C. W. D. A. AND AND I'LL LET
THEM TESTIFY TO THEIR POSITION --
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AND AND
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THESE ARE THEIR CONCERNS ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN WORK ON I
WITH THAT -- I WILL CLOSE AND
AFTER I VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITH A KEVIN AS
THE COALITION CALIFORNIA ROUGH
RIGHT SIR GUYS ISSHIN.
THIS BILL BASICALLY FIXES AN
OVERSIGHT THAT WAS DONE.
BECAUSE OF DRAFTING ERROR OF THE
WATER BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY ATTENDANT THAT A WOMAN.
WHO HAS -- WHO HAS NOTHING?
LIVE IN THE STREETS RATHER THAN
GETTING GENERAL ASSISTANCE AND
HOPEFULLY GET OFF THE STREETS SO
WE ARE DRIVE WITH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'M CONCERNED WHERE WOULD YOU
LIKE ME.
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR
WITH CONCERNS.
THANK YOU ADJUSTING GARETH
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WERE NOT OPPOSITION BUT
WE DID HAVE SOME CONCERNS AS A
GESTURE WITH YOU -- SO GENERAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ARE ENTIRELY
UNDER PERCENT COUNTY FUNDED --
AND EACH COUNTY HAS THE ABILITY
TO MAKE THEIR OWN DETERMINATIONS
OF ELIGIBILITY AND I'M BENEFIT
PAYMENTS TO THOSE PROGRAM SO
WE'VE EXPRESSED SOME.
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THIS BILL AS WELL
AS LOCAL COST CONCERNS -- AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT WE'VE WE SHARE
THESE CONCERNS WITH BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR -- OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN RELATES TO THE
LANGUAGE WE BELIEVE GOES BEYOND
THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR TO ALSO
OPEN UP -- J. BENEFITS TO THOSE
WHO ARE SANCTIONED ARE PENALIZED
AND I WITH -- APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS ON
THOSE -- AND SO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER -- TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS -- LOOKING FOR WITH
THIS BILL AND APPRECIATE THE
OPENNESS OF THE AUTHOR -- IN
RESPONSE ON THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NOW LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR STONE.
SOME HAVE MISS KOREA THANK YOU
FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD.
I THINK THIS ALSO MAYBE WAS
DRAFTING ERROR BUT IN OUR ZEAL.
YEARS AGO NOT OURS BUT IN THIS.
ZERO TO CONTROL OR DENY PEOPLE
BENEFITS ACROSS THE BOARD.
WE WE CAUSAL A VERY WE CREATE A
VERY COMPLEX SYSTEM.
THAT DENIES PEOPLE AND IS WAS
REALLY SET UP TO DO THAT.
SO ANY ATTEMPT THAT WE'RE MAKING
NOW TO KIND OF CHIP AWAY AT THE
IRRATIONALITY OF THOSE SYSTEMS
THE THESE ABILITY TO DENY PEOPLE
THESE BILLION TO SORT OF SET UP
ALL OF THE HURDLES THAT WE SET
UP IS REALLY A GOOD THING.
I WOULD HOPE AT SOME POINT WE
COULD DO A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK.
AT WHAT WE WOULD LIKE THE
ENTITLEMENT SYSTEM TO LOOK LIKE
VERSUS HOW IT'S BEEN COBBLED
TOGETHER AS WE SORT OF PEACE
THESE THINGS TOGETHER THEN WE
WOULD HAVING A MUCH BETTER IDEA
OF HOW TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT THE COUNTIES HAVE.
BECAUSE IT'S AN IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUE ULTIMATELY WE WE DON'T
WANT TO BE.
THE NINE PEOPLE ACCESS TO
BENEFITS THAT REALLY HELP THEM
GET OUT OF POVERTY THAT THAT THE
SYSTEM IN THE COMMUNITIES.
WE GET OUR SYSTEM DOES THAT.
BECAUSE OF OUR YOU COULD
CYNICALLY SAY WAS INTENTIONAL
BUT I THINK IT WAS THAT A LOT OF
WAYS. TO DENY ACCESS TO IT A
NUMBER OF FOLKS SO IT'S GOOD
THAT WE'RE WORKING AT THIS BUT I
THINK THE FRUSTRATION IS IS
WE'RE JUST SORT OF LOOKING AT
BITS AND PIECES AND YES I'VE GOT
SOME BILLS IN THIS AREA AS WELL.
BUT I THINK WE SHOULD LOOK MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY AT SOME POINT AT
THE OVERALL SYSTEM AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S RATIONAL AND THAT
WE'RE HELPING THE PEOPLE THAT WE
NEED TO HELP.
SO OUT ALL MOVE THE BILL.
STILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
TWELVE SECOND [inaudible]
SECOND.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE -- MRS
DOLE'S COMMENTS AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY CONVEY THOSE MESSAGE
BACK TO MISS CARILLO AND I'M
SURE BECAUSE I KNOW MISS CARILLO
SHE WOULD DO EVERYTHING SHE CAN
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
FIND.
A BALANCE IN THIS BILL SOLD ARE
STRICTLY ASPEN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU AND ON BEHALF OF MISS CREEL
DO YOU YOU DO EXCEPT I DO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TAKE THE ROLE PLEASE
WE HAVE MOTION BY MISTER STONE
SECOND BY MISTER GIBSON.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
YES I RAMOS I AM MATHIS.
BERMAN.
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON FI GIPSON I MAIENSCHEIN
STONE STONE HI.
WE HAVE THREE TWO ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MR FRAZIER.
WE HAVE AB EIGHT TWELVE AND AB
EIGHT THIRTEEN WHICH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO START WITH [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
AB [inaudible]
EIGHT THIRTEEN GREATER.
I'M SORRY. FIVE POINT.
SINCE CATCHING THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER ON ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN AB EIGHT THIRTEEN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LET ME
START BY SAYING YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL COMMITTEE.
US SECRETARY.
WHO WAS ON MY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE SHE WILL BE VERY PROUD
[inaudible]
SHE HAS.
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY -- I WANT
TO THANK YOU MEDICARE AND AND
MEMBERS.
AB FOR EIGHTEEN THIRTY AB.
EIGHT THIRTEEN POSES AN
ALTERNATIVE APPEAL PROCEDURE.
THAT WILL PLEASE.
WE'LL PLACE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
RESOURCES INSIDE THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
I HAVE TOURED THE STATE AS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FOR INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
LISTENING TO FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS AND REGIONAL CENTERS.
IN GETTING THE GRASS ROOTS
FEELING A WHAT'S GOING WRONG IN
THE SYSTEM.
AS YOU KNOW THE REGIONAL CENTERS
WERE DEVELOPED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN AND THEY'RE STILL
THE STATUS QUO AND WE'VE EVOLVED.
OUR POPULATION IS OF ALL AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD.
TO STARTING A PROCESS AS THE
CHAIRMAN AND YOU KNOW MY PASSION
FOR THIS WONDERFUL POPULATION.
I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT --
OFTENTIMES -- IN THIS PROCESS.
WHAT THEY OFFER THESE EXHAUSTED
PARENTS OF FACE TO FACE WITH
RESOURCES WHEN DENIED SERVICES?
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT SERVICES ARE
DENIED.
AND AS OPPOSED TO HAVING A
FIGURE TO FIGURE OUT WHY THEY
WERE DENIED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
LET ME READ OUT SOME VOICES FROM
FRUSTRATED DEFEATED PARENTS.
CONSTANTLY ADVOCATING MEANS LESS
TIME TO ACTUALLY BE WITH AND
HELP MY SON.
IT'S A BROKEN SYSTEM.
WE HAVE NO ONE TO HELP US I NEED
A BREAK FROM THE DAILY REACHING
RE ROUTINE THIS JOB IS TAXING.
IN ITS.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN I HAVE
PREVAILED BUT ONLY WITH AN
ENORMOUS PERSONAL EFFORT THAT
WOULD BE DIFFICULT FOR MOST
FAMILIES LET ALONE INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMERS TO MUSTER.
THIS TESTIMONY COMES FROM
PARENTS WITH LAW DEGREES HIGH
LEVEL BUSINESS EXPERIENCE.
ALL OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES OF
FOR PARENTS. FOR THOSE LADIES
WHO COME FROM SINGLE PARENT
HOUSEHOLDS OR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
APPEALS ARE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM RELIES ON
PARENTS TO DO ALL THE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THEIR LOVED.
ONE IF A PARENT DOESN'T HAVE A
FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULE FOR IF
THEY HAVE A LANGUAGE BARRIER OR
IF THEY WERE REAL -- BLACK
RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION.
THEY DON'T HAVE A CHANCE.
AB EIGHT THIRTEEN WILL GIVE
EVERY CLIENT WITH ID DE.
A FIGHTING CHANCE THEY DESERVE
TO GET THE SERVICES THEY NEED.
WE NEED TO FIND AVENUES OF FIXES
THAT WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE
[inaudible]
TODAY.
I HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT RANDY NOT APPARENT.
AN ADVOCATE TO SHARE HER STORY
AND ALSO RENEE CALLAWAY A SINGLE
MOTHER ALSO.
WHO WAS DENIED SERVICES FOR FIVE
YEARS [inaudible]
RANDY.
YOUR FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RANDY NOT.
I AM A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE BY
TRADE SO YOU MAY HAVE SEEN ME IN
OTHER PLACES BUT I'M HERE TODAY
IS PRESLEY'S MOM.
MY SON PRESLEY WAS BORN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE AND WHEN HE
WAS TWO YEARS OLD THEY TOLD US
HE WOULD NEVER SPEAK NEVER POTTY
TRAIN WE SHOULD SET UP A
SUPPORTING LIVING ACCOUNT.
AND LOVE HIM AS HE IS -- WE
BROUGHT HIM INTO EARLY START.
AND BEING A POLITICAL PERSON BY
NATURE I GOT APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER TO THE
STATE COUNCIL INVOLVING -- BUT
DISABILITIES TO THE AREA BOARD
AND BECAME QUITE ACTIVE IN MY
SON'S.
I. P. P. AND THE SERVICES BEING
OFFERED TO HIM.
I HOLD A MASTERS IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION OF PUBLIC POLICY
AND I'VE WORKED IN GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR TWENTY YEARS.
I CAN PROMISE YOU.
THAT IF I DID NOT HAVE THAT
BACKGROUND AND DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
THE LAW MY SON WOULD NOT BE THE
SUCCESS STORY THAT HE IS TODAY.
JUST TO CATCH UP HE DOESN'T SHUT
UP AND HE'S PERFECTLY POTTY
TRAINED I'M.
HE IS AT A HIGH PERFORMING
ACADEMIC CHARTER SCHOOL YET
BECAUSE I HAVE THE BEST SERVICE
COORDINATOR.
AND I KNOW THE SYSTEM AND I KNOW
WHAT TO DEMAND AND I HAVE THE
DISPOSABLE INCOME IN THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THAT TIME OFF.
AND FIGHT.
I HAVE GONE TO OVER ONE HUNDRED
IP PEAS AND I EAT PEAS FOR
PARENTS WHO CAN'T PEOPLE AND I
DON'T CHARGE THEM THIS IS MY MY
KARMA THING. TO HELP PEOPLE
BECAUSE WHAT WHAT THEY SAID
WOULD HAPPEN TO MY SON DIDN'T.
BUT I CAN'T BEGIN TO TELL YOU
HOW MANY PEOPLE I MEET IN TRADER
JOE'S AND SOMEBODY ELSE'S
BECAUSE IN IN MY GRANDSON.
THAT I GO AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IF
I GO TO THAT MEETING IF THEY
HAVE TIME TO DO THE SECOND
MEETING AND THEY KNOW ENOUGH. TO
ASK FOR AN APPEAL I'M SITTING
THERE LOOKING LIKE A LAWYER THE
REGIONAL CENTER GET SCARED AND
THEY GIVE THEM WHAT THEY WANT
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WHY AREN'T
THE MOMS WHO ARE IT IS WHITE AND
PRIVILEGED AS ME GETTING WHAT
THEY WANT AND NEED.
IS IT THE END OF THE DAY.
AT THE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WE AS A SOCIETY HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF THESE CHILDREN IF WE GO
BACK.
TO THEN GOVERNOR REAGAN WHO
CREATED THE LANHAM ACT THERE WAS
STILL A PHILOSOPHY THAT A
SOCIETY WOULD BE JUDGED ON HOW
IT TREATS ITS MOST VULNERABLE
CITIZENS.
IN THIS CASE THE PARENTS ARE
BEING DENIED THERE EITHER WAY TO
RURAL AND THEY CAN'T GET RESPITE
OR THEY HAVE MINIMUM WAGE JOBS
THEY NEED TO KEEP OR THEIR THEIR
CHILD'S OWN CARE GIVER.
THERESHOULD BE.
EITHER THROUGH THE STATE COUNCIL
THROUGH THE AREA BOARDS
INDEPENDENT ADVOCATE THAT DON'T
COST MONEY THAT CAN HELP PEOPLE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS SO THEY CAN
GET THEIR CHILDREN WHAT THEY
NEED.
AND THEY CAN HAVE THE SAME KIND
OF SUCCESS STORY THAT I'VE HAD
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THAT
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RENEE
CALLAWAY AND MY SON HAS BEEN
DENIED BY THE REGIONAL CENTER --
FOR FAR TOO LONG.
THEY HAVE FELT OUT MY SON FOR
MORE THAN FIVE YEARS.
SORRY GET A MOTION WHEN I TALK
ABOUT.
I GIVE YOU ALL THE PICTURE OF
HIM I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
THEM.
BUT THAT'S MY SON JEREMY.
I'VE GOT MY PICK MY PICTURE.
SORRY SO IN JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GERMS CASE MANAGER CAME
INTO THE HOME LIKE SHE DOES
EVERY YEAR.
FOR HIS ANNUAL REVIEW.
AND HE WAS DENIED SERVICES --
AGAIN.
AND DAYS PAST MY CASE MANAGER
WHAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF THESE
MEETINGS OR THESE REVIEWS IF
HE'S NOT GETTING ANY SERVICES
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER.
AND SHE SAID JUST TO KEEP THEM
IN THE SYSTEM.
I IN APRIL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
JEREMY BECAME INCREASINGLY MORE
VIOLENT TOWARDS ME.
AND HE STOPPED WEARING HIS
SEATBELT AND HE WOULD HIT ME AND
KICK ME AS I WAS DRIVING -- I
WAS KERN CONCERNED FOR HIS
SAFETY MY SAFETY AND THE SAFETY
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
I CALLED A CASE MANAGER AND HOW
TO COME BACK OUT TO THE HOME.
BECAUSE I NEEDED HELP.
AND AT THAT TIME SHE SAID HE
QUALIFIED FOR RESPITE SERVICES.
AND BEFORE SHE LEFT SHE'S GONNA
MAIL ME APPEAL LESS AND THIS WAS
AN I APRIL.
I START SPENDING LESS AND LESS
TIME WITH JEREMY AND AND NEEDED
THE RESPITE SUPPORT SO I CAN
SPEND TIME WITH MY SON -- THE
CASE MANAGER CALLED ME A MONTH
LATER.
AND WITH HER SUPERVISOR AND THEY
REFUSE TO GIVE ME THE HOURS --
SHE THEN QUESTION GERMANY'S DADS
I HSS HOURS.
AND I WAS FEARFUL OF LOSING
THOSE HOURS IN THE SERVICES THAT
I CURRENTLY HAD -- AFTER THAT
CONVERSATION SO I JUST KIND OF
BACKED OFF.
AND THEN IN OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HIGH WENT
SPOKE AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRASIER'S -- TOWN HALL MEETING
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER ABOUT
HOW I'VE BEEN DENIED SERVICES
FOR SO LONG.
I WAS THEN GRANTED -- POS -- BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER -- SHORTLY
AFTER THE TOWN HALL.
I THE CASE MANAGER THE DIRECTOR
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER NANCY
BARGE MEN AND CHRISTIAN RIGHTS
OFFICE MET IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER'S OFFICE TO DISCUSS THE
DENIALS.
AND FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER.
THE CASE WORKER HI THAT WAS
THERE WAS ROUTE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER TALKED OVER HIM --
SHE WAS AGGRESSIVE IN HER
RESPONSES AS THE DIRECTOR SAT
THERE IN SILENCE.
I POINTED OUT -- TO THE ROOM HAS
THAT IF THE CASE MANAGER ACTS
LIKE THIS IN FRONT OF PEOPLE
LIKE YOU WHAT DO YOU THINK SHE'S
DOING IN THE HOME. TO THE
FAMILIES.
I AT THAT POINT -- THE DIRECTOR
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER APPROVED
MY RESPITE HOURS.
THE SYSTEM CANNOT FILL MORE
FAMILIES LIKE IT HAS FILLED MINE
I DO WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR BEING
THE VOICE FOR SO MANY.
THAT DO NOT HAVE.
ONE I AND I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE EFFORTS OF CLIENTS TO
IMPROVE THEIR SITUATION BY
GIVING THEM THE TOOLS TO MAKE
REAL CHANGE.
I IN THE SERVICES THEY RECEIVE
IN THE LIFE THEY LIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
I'M BOB PLAN TOLD FROM GENESIS
WHICH IS A FAITH COMMUNITY LABOR
ORGANIZATION.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER SPELL AND WE
THANK HIM WHEN HE CAME TO OUR
OCTOBER GENERAL MEETING. FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE SHOWED UP MANY OF
THEM EXPRESSED CONCERN THE
SERVICES THEY WERE GETTING.
WERE FOUGHT HARD TO GET BUT ALSO
SEEM TO BE SUBJECT TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE STAFF.
THIS LEADS TO DISCREPANCIES IN
THE SERVICES IN A VERY UNCLEAR
LABORIOUS APPEALS PROCESS.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT WE SHOULD DO
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TROUBLING FOR
THOSE WHO MAY NOT BE FULLY
FLUENT IN ENGLISH OR WHO MAY NOT
HAVE TIME TO LEAVE HOME BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE SOLE PARENT CARE
GIVER OF THE CHILD.
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN WE ARE
CONCERNED AGAIN ABOUT THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES WE HAVE FOUR
DIFFERENT OB LETTERS STATE WE
WILL GIVE YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BUT ON THE FACT THAT THIS.
ONE THERE STERN CHARTS AND
STATISTICS TO INDICATE THERE'S
REAL EVIDENCE OF RACIAL
DISPARITY.
IN FOR THOSE REASONS WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER WE
SUPPORT HIM.
I SAY THIS NOT JUST AS A MATTER
OF PRINCIPLE.
I HAVE A COUSIN WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY AND
I'VE GOT FRIENDS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES SO
FOR US.
IT'S PERSONAL AND IT'S FAMILY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE JUST
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
WHEN I THOUGHT OF THIS THE
NUMBER IS OUT IN THE FINAL?
HE SO I'M ON MY THEY'LL NINO FOR
NOW WITH THE SMALL.
KEY A MISCREANT OTHER CENTER
LIKE YOU'RE NOT DEAD BODY MONTH
TIME.
TAMBIéN SO YOU MEMBER THERE FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA. FOR SOCIAL NEED US
THIS WILL NOT WORK ANY SAYS YOU
OWN AND FOR THE BODY OF THE
PROPOSED THAT BY THAT IS ENOUGH
IDEAS THAT IS GOING TO LOVE THIS
TIME JOAQUIN ESRB FLOWERS.
THE SYSTEM ALSO MONEY FOUND A
PRODUCT THEY ARE FROM THE US IN
THOSE THEY AFFECT THEM WITH US
FROM MEDIA.
THIS COULD BE.
A YES I GOT THE STEAM ON YOU
YEAH WHAT A SUPPLEMENT THIS
TICKET INTO KNOWN BUT ANY LOUDER
THAN HE SAYS HE ON EITHER GOT
ASSIST OTHER QUIRK THOUGH GOLD
HE WITH GENESIS AND GIVE VALLEY
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RUSSELL RAWLINGS WITH CAPITAL
REGIONAL ORGANIZING PROJECT AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HEARING KERR OTHERS PIC
COUNSELING DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JERRY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TAYLOR ASH FOR EASTER SEALS BAY
AREA MORE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CARMEN DOOR GARDI PARENTS
EMPOWERING PARENTS SOMEWHERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ADRIANA DHEAS PARENT TO PARENT
PARENTS AND WENT SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI ANGEL HICKS IN AN ADVOCATE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICOLE NAFF PARENT ADVOCATE
PARENTS EMPOWERING PARENTS.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER CARPENTER PARENTS
EMPOWERING PARENTS AND A PARENT
ADVOCATE.
THANK YOU.
PAM DEBBIE TELLS WITH CHOICE AN
AGING -- ON BEHALF OF THE
ORGANIZATION I'M ALSO THE MOTHER
OF A SPECIAL NEEDS BOY THANK YOU
AND SPIKE YOU.
JUSTIN CHILDREN WITH SAINT
MARK'S HARMONY CENTER AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- JENNY LENTON PARENT
OF A SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD.
WELL THIS THIRTY TWO AND A BOARD
MEMBER SPECIAL TO KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PATRICK THIS PIECE -- PARENT OF
A SPECIAL NEEDS -- CHILD AND I'M
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
I WILL SECOND IT.
BUT I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS MR
FRAZIER -- AND SOME COMMENTS.
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CURRENT DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS WHAT DOES IT
LOOK LIKE. TWO RIGHT NOW.
THEY YOUR SUBMITTED A SEVEN PAGE
DOCUMENT.
THAT IN THE IN THE MIDST OF IT
SOMEWHERE.
IS THE ABILITY THAT YOU CAN.
WHAT I'VE FOUND IN MY TRAVELS IS
A MOST PARENTS?
NOTE ONLY GO TO THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR IT'S NOT
ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR THE DENIAL HAPPENS.
USUALLY IT STEPS UP TO MAYBE THE
SUPERVISOR OF THE OF THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR.
AND THEN IN DIDN'T MISS CAL WAYS
OF SITUATION WHEN THAT HAPPENED.
BOTH TEAMED UP HONOR AND
SCREAMED AT HER OVER THE
TELEPHONE [inaudible]
THAT'S UNCONSCIONABLE.
THAT BEING SAID.
WE HAD A TOWN HALL AND BRENT
WOULD I BELIEVE IT WAS ABOUT
THREE WEEKS AGO AND WAS VERY
KIND OF THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER TO COME
OUT. FOR ME STAY.
FIRST TIME EVER.
BUT THERE WAS OVER A HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
AND IT WAS STANDING ROOM ONLY.
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE WERE
THIRSTY FOR INFORMATION ON HOW.
THEY COULD ACTUALLY BE SERVED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER.
THAT BEING SAID.
THE EXACT ADDRESS EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGED IF IT EVER GOT TO
HER LEVEL [inaudible]
EVER.
ALL THE NILES WERE GENERALLY
APPROVED.
SO THIS LEVEL OF GATEKEEPING
SCOTT A STOCK.
AND IF THE PARENTS KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE AN ABILITY TO GO TO A
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS IF
THEY'RE DENIED BUT LET ME SHARE
WITH YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THERE NEVER TOLD WHAT THEY CAN
QUALIFY.
FOR THERE'S NO MENU OF SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED.
SO THERE AT THE AT THE ABSOLUTE
[inaudible]
ABSOLUTE.
WILL OF THE SERVICE COORDINATOR
COORDINATOR YES THEY HAVE THE
ADEQUATE TRAINING. TO BE ABLE TO
ADMINISTER TO THAT CHILD OR
ADULT.
I'M JUST ASKING THAT WE START A
PROCESS THAT ACTUALLY EVERYBODY
HAS A FAIR CHANCE.
BECAUSE IN THIS CULTURE.
IT'S THE CULTURE OF NO.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN.
THROUGH THIS WHOLE PROCESS AND
IF WE CAN ACTUALLY AND I BELIEVE
THERE WERE BACK IN A TIME PERIOD
WINDOW.
STATE WAS ACTUALLY MORE ENGAGED.
THERE WAS THIS PROCESS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS.
GOING FOR BUT IT WAS DEMISED.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO THAT SO
THE PEOPLE THAT I CARE ABOUT.
THE ID POPULATION CAN FLOURISH.
WILL YOUR BILL.
INTERACT WITH THE EXISTING --
PROCESS FOR APPEALS.
SO WHAT WE'RE HOPING.
FOR IS TO START A DIALOGUE.
THIS BILL IS JUST IN HOPES THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY KNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE IS A PROBLEM.
AND THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT WE
CAN WORK WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
THAT ACTUALLY KNOWLEDGE IS THAT.
THE PEOPLE'S THE PARENTS VOICES
MATTER.
THAT THEY'RE NOT BEING PROVIDED
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SERVICES.
AND IF THE ONLY WAY THEY
ACTUALLY LEARN TO HELP GET
SERVICES HIS REPAIR NETWORKS
BLOGS AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAD TO BEG.
THE REGIONAL SERVICE BAY TO
ACTUALLY PUT THE MENU OF
SERVICES.
ON THEIR WEBSITE.
ALL I'M ASKING IS A FAIR CHANCE
TO BE ABLE TO START A PROCESS TO
THE PARENTS HAVE A VOICE.
AND HOW THAT HAPPENS I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO WORK MADAM
CHAIR. TO MAKE SURE THAT PROCESS
HAPPENS.
WONDERFUL IT.
NOW WHAT ABOUT PAYMENT FOR THE
SERVICE IF FOR HAVING A DISPUTE
RESOLUTION NSIDE
ORGANIZATION BUT WILL THIS BE
FREE TO THE CONSUMER TO THE
PARENTS YES MA'AM OKAY.
MR HOLDEN AND I HAVE A BILL THAT
AUGMENTS.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS IN
PROVIDERS BY TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS IT'S AN
EIGHT AND I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE STATE PERCENT BRIDGE
MONEY.
AS YOU AS YOU SAW THAT WHEN THE
RATE STUDY CAME OUT.
THAT WE'VE BEEN UNDER FUNDING.
UNDER FUNDING THE ID POPULATION
BY ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS [inaudible]
THAT'S CRIMINAL.
IT IS A WE'RE HEARING FROM
JUSTICE MISTER KALRA PRESENTED.
ON SS I SS P. -- WITH THE WITH
THE BUDGET PROBLEMS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT IT'S ON THE BACKS
OF THE LEAST.
THEN THE MOST VULNERABLE THE
LEAST.
ABLE TO WITHSTAND IT -- THE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM AS
WE KNOW SERVICE OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS.
EACH OF WHOM HAS VARYING NEEDS.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS THAT THOSE NEEDS BE MET.
AND THAT THERE IS RECOURSE WHEN
THEY ARE NOT.
CLEARLY WE HAVE EXAMPLES WHERE
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN MET.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT TODAY ABOUT
THE NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
OVERSIGHT.
AND I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE TO ENSURE THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTER CONSUMERS HAVE RECOURSE
WHEN SERVICES ARE DENIED.
OR WHEN THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT A DECISION REGARDING THE
SERVICE.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO BE SURE THAT
THE PROCESS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE.
USES THE RESOURCES EFFICIENTLY.
AND THAT WE ARE REDUNDANT.
WITH THE CURRENT PROCESS IT'S
BEING USED.
IF THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH THE
PROCESS WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT
THAT.
BECAUSE IF IT IS BEING OFFERED
TO FOR DISPUTE RESOLUTION BEING
USED IMPROPERLY WE CERTAINLY
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THAT THE VOICE OF CONSUMERS.
THEIR FAMILIES ARE
REPRESENTATIVES AND ADVOCATES
ARE HEARD.
AND THAT THEY BE THE DRIVING
FACTOR BEHIND THIS CHANGE I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE YOU ARE
CHAMPION. FOR THE COMMUNITY IN
THIS AREA AND YOUR VOICE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND IT'S
CLEAR TO ME WHEN YOU HAVE A TOWN
HALL.
THAT YOU HAVE THE COMMUNITY COME
OUT IN MY HOUSE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY WILL BE HEARD THAT YOU
WILL BE SURE TO BRING THE RIGHT
ADVOCATES TO WHATEVER HEARING
YOU HAVE.
SO I DO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISTER GIBSON AND THE SECOND
BY ME.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HIS
MANAGER AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR KIND CONSIDERATION.
I KNOW YOU TO BE THE CHAMPION
ALSO OF ALL UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
I BEG. TO TO BE IT.
PUT ON BUDGET SUB ONE WHICH
YOU'RE NOW THE CHAIR.
I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH.
NOT ONLY FROM YOU BUT FROM THE
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME.
BEFORE US.
ON HOW WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB.
IN THE STATE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE RATE STUDY
THE CAME OUT?
AND WE LOOK AT OTHER AGENCIES
THAT HAVE NOT FUNDED SINCE THE
RECESSION.
AND BROUGHT US BACK.
TO WHERE WE SHOULD BE EVEN WITH
THE COST OF INFLATION OR
INDEXING.
GOING FORWARD I WILL TELL YOU
[inaudible]
THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DO AS A POPULATION WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND AND CATCH BACK UP.
WE NEED TO CATCH BACK UP.
AND RIGHT NOW THE SYSTEM.
AND IT'S BEEN SAID BY A MOTHER.
THE RIGHT NOW THE ID POPULATION
IS B. GROUP BEING PREPARED. TO
GO GROUPON'S.
NOT TO FLOURISH.
AND THAT'S NOT FAIR.
IT'S NOT RIGHT IT IS NOT RIGHT.
WITH THAT [inaudible]
I ABSOLUTELY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
PLEASE TAKE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
RANTS HI RES I AM MATHIS.
BERMAN.
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON GIPSON I MAIENSCHEIN
STONE.
WE HAVE TWO ZERO ONLY BECAUSE
YOU ONLY HAVE TO MEMBERS HERE --
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MANAGER
THANK YOU.
SENATE WE CAN HELP TO PROTECT.
RIGHT MISTER SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THE YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON ITEM
NUMBER.
THIRTEEN THE BOX OF YEAH AB.
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WHAT THE
TRIGGER FOR BREVITY.
CHAIR ALWAYS PREFERS BREVITY WE
WANT TO WIN WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT THE INFORMATION NEEDED.
IS PRESENTED.
IT IS JUST MYSELF [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS COMES
ON THE HEELS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
APPROVING.
AB TO ATTEND WHICH WE DID A FEW
YEARS AGO -- TO ALLOW -- FOR
HOMELESS SERVICES DODD TO BE
COORDINATED -- AT THE BACK AND
THAT MEANS WHEN SOMEBODY IS ON
THE STREETS AND THEY NEED THAT
HELP WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS
TAKING THE SAME APPROACH -- ANY
BEES SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT TO ALLOW
FOR THAT SORT OF COORDINATION ON
THE FRONT AND TO PREVENT.
OF TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS AND SO WE'RE
PROPOSING NTV'S TO ENGAGE IN
THESE PREVENTIVE STRATEGIES AND
COORDINATE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
BILL FOR WORKING WITH US -- AND
HELPING US TO MAKE THIS A BETTER
BILL WITH US WE HAVE ONE WITNESS
ALSO FROM LA COUNTY THANK YOU
YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- TO THE
HONORABLE CHAIR AND THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FEES YET DAVENPORT I'M AN
ASSISTANT CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER IN THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICE FOR THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES.
AND JUST FOLLOWING UP ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO'S
COMMENTS WE SEE AB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT AS A LOGICAL EXTENSION OF
AB TWO TEN WE KNOW THAT SO OFTEN
WE ENGAGE IN POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES -- TO ADDRESS CURRENT
ISSUES BUT WE DON'T ALWAYS PAY A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF ATTENTION
TO THE THE SPACE THAT PREVENTION
AND SO AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
IT'S FOCUSED ON A PREVENTION --
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN COMBAT
ENOUGH -- THE THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION WE ARE MAKING VERY
GOOD PROGRESS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE PASSIVITY PASSAGE OF AB
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD JUST BE
ONE MORE.
TOOL IN OUR ARSENAL IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST HOMELESSNESS AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU -- TO ADOPT AND
VOTE YES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HI DEBRA CURLED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JIMMY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
[inaudible]
TO THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THAT'S ME.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS TO YOU YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT OFTENTIMES WE
JUST LOOK AT THE PROBLEM WHEN
IT'S ALREADY BEFORE US.
AS OPPOSED TO TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING.
AND I AM STALLING SO THAT WE CAN
GET SOMEONE TO GET MAKE A MOTION --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- YES
MADAM CHAIR I I APPRECIATE YOUR
HELP ON THIS AND THE RESPECT WE
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND ALL THAT MATTERED TO ME AS
YOU WERE HERE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO MOVE.
WE'RE PROMOTION SECOND PLEASE
TAKE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
RAY YES HI RES I AM MATHIS.
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN
STONE. TWO VOTES.
THANK YOU WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB [inaudible]
FOUR FIFTY TWO SECOND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
AND MEMBER.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES MEMINTA THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL AB FOR FIFTY
TWO SIX TO CONVERT THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE FACILITIES
REVOLVING FUND.
INTO THE CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE
FACILITIES GRANT TO FUND.
REPORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE OVER
THE LAST DECADE REFLECT THAT THE
FUND HAS BEEN SEVERELY UNDER
UTILIZED.
DURING THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FISCAL YEAR THE
REVOLVING FUND DID NOT RECEIVE A
SINGLE APPLICATION.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OVERHAUL THE
FUNDING CONVERTED TO A GRAND
FUND HAVE COME FROM BRIEFS BY
THE ADVANCEMENT PROJECT IN A
DRAFT OF THE SPEAKERS BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY CHRISTOPHER
MERRICK CALL.
UP EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HEAD
START CALIFORNIA AND TAP WITH
THE THOMPSON HEAD START DIRECTOR
WITH TWIN RIVERS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A CUSTOMER GO HEAD START
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HEAD START
GRANTEES SERVING OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST AT
RISK CHILDREN.
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN FOR BRINGING FORTH
THE LEGISLATION AND TWO IS CO
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
WE KNOW THERE'S A VERY LARGE
SERVICE GAP IN THIS AREA AND THE
NEED FOR INFANT AND TODDLER CARE
FAR OUTSTRIPS AVAILABILITY.
THERE ARE BARRIERS TO REDUCING
THAT GAP AND FACILITIES IS ONE
OF THEM.
ACCORDING TO A MAY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STUDY BY THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
THERE WAS AN ESTIMATED
210-004-0070 SEVEN CHILDREN AGED
HERE TO TO WHO NEEDED.
BUT DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE JUST IN THE SAN JOSE
SUNNYVALE SANTA CLARA
METROPOLITAN AREA.
THE COUNTY OFFICE ESTIMATED THE
AVERAGE COST FOR FACILITIES TO
SERVE TWENTY CHILDREN.
AT EIGHT ZERO TWO AT ABOUT A
QUARTER OF A MILLION FOR
PORTABLE BUILDING. FIVE AND
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND TO RENOVATE
AN EXISTING FACILITY.
AND ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION SO JUST TO
TAKE CARE OF THE GAP IN THE IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA.
IS ABOUT A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS.
SO THIS LEGISLATION IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD CLOSING
THAT GAP AND IT DOES TO GREAT
THINGS IT MAKES MORE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO RENOVATE AND
CONSTRUCT SO IT IS FOR THE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO THAT
FUNDING TO MORE PROVIDERS BOTH
ELEAZAR NANI -- ELEAZAR RUNNING
FEDERAL AND OR STATE SUBSIDIZED
PROGRAMS SO WE BELIEVE THE SINCE
THIS WILL INCENTIVIZE PROVIDERS.
TO DEVELOP THE FACILITY TO SERVE
THOSE CHILDREN AND HEAD START
CALIFORNIA IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR THOMPSON
THE HEAD START DIRECTOR FOR TWIN
RIVERS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND WE US
SERVE OUR POPULATION OF T. K.
THROUGH ADULT ED. TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS A LITTLE OVER
ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE
INFANTS TODDLERS AND
PRESCHOOLERS -- I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GRANT FOR
FACILITIES FOR ONE PRIMARY
REASON AND THAT IS BECAUSE WE
CANNOT OF SERVING THE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
FACILITIES.
OF MANY OF OUR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE EXTRA SPACE
BECAUSE THEY ARE SERVING OUR
OLDER STUDENTS AND MANY OF THE
FACILITIES WERE BUILT IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES
WHICH MEANS THAT THEY REQUIRE
SOME UPGRADES.
AND RENOVATIONS TO EVEN HOUSE
ANY OF OUR YOUNGER LEARNERS -- I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT IN --
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TOWARD
NUMBERS APPLIED FOR AND RECEIVED
A GRANT TO HOUSEHOLDS -- AND
MAKE A PORTABLE MODULAR AND A
PLAYGROUND AND IT WAS A LITTLE
OVER MILLION DOLLARS TO SERVE A
FORTY ADDITIONAL STUDENTS AND
THE NORTH HIGHLANDS AREA -- THIS
IS AGAIN ONE OF OUR STRUGGLES IS
THAT WE OF COURSE WANT -- TO
SUPPORT MORE STUDENTS THAT ARE
OF THE YOUNGER AGE BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE FACILITIES SO WOULD BE -- A
BENEFIT FOR US IF WE COULD
INDEED GET SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR FACILITIES SO I SAY TO YOU
THAT IF YOU BUILD IT THEY WILL
COME.
THANK YOU NEXT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
MR MULLIN YOUR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
YES THANK YOU.
HI MICHELLE STILL PREVENTS HE
REPRESENTING CONTANGO IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HIGH TEMPERATURES REPRESENTING
TROUT THREE SIXTY LOS ANGELES
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EARLY
LEARNING MISSION NEIGHBORHOOD
CENTERS AND THE EASY FACILITIES
CAMPAIGN COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO JUSTIN ARE PELTING WITH
EARLY I'M SORRY EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ON A HASSELBLAD WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JERRY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I CAN TAKE QUESTIONS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CNN IF AND CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I AM COMMITTEES WITH EARLY AGE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE LA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CATIONS AREA ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK AND CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE MOTION.
OKAY.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MOVED I
SECONDED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I AM
MATHIS [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
YOU HAVE TO VOTES.
TWO ZERO BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
YOU ARE PRESENTING ON ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN B. [inaudible]
TWELVE TWENTY NINE HI MY PERSONS
TESTIFYING WITH ME WHO WAS HERE.
I SEE SOMEBODY [inaudible]
HI.
BEEN WITH THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBER.
AND EVERYONE ELSE WHO'S HERE.
A MAJORITY FOSTER YOUTH ASPIRE
TO HIGHER EDUCATION HOWEVER ONLY
324% OF FOSTER YOUTH EARNED A
BACHELOR DEGREE IN LESS THAN 1%
WILL OBTAIN A MASTER'S OR
DOCTORATE DEGREE.
ISSUES OF HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS ARE PREVALENT ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND MANY
STUDENTS STRUGGLE WITH THE
RISING COST OF BASIC NEEDS AND
LIVING.
MANY FOSTER YOUTH DEPEND ON
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AND
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS SUCH AS CAL
FRESH.
AND A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR THAT
LEADS.
TO LOW HIGHER EDUCATION
ATTAINMENT FOR FOSTER YOUTH IS
THE LACK OF FINANCIAL STABILITY.
AND OTHER SUPPORT FOR MORE
TRADITIONAL STUDENTS.
THE MORE TRADITIONAL STUDENTS
RECEIVE.
A COLLEGE EDUCATION IS NECESSARY
FOR MANY YOUTH SUCH.
SUCH AS FOSTER YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
pBE SUCCESSFUL AND STAYS ECONOMY.
WE SHOULD TAKE STEPS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO CAL FRESH FOR FOSTER
YOUTH STUDENTS.
I CAN THINK OF NO MORE IMPORTANT
BASIC RATE THAN ACCESS TO FOOD.
WHAT DO WE DO IF WE CAN'T EAT?
CAL PRECIOUS SESSION HOW FRESH
PROVIDES PEOPLE WITH ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS.
THAT SUPPORT THEIR HEALTH WELL
BEING AND SCHOOL AND WORK
READINESS.
MY BILL A AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
WILL ONE ESTABLISH A MEAL
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOU TO
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL CAL FIRST
BENEFITS. FOR FOSTER USED TO
COMPANY THEIR HOUSING SUPPORT
PAYMENTS. THREE ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENT WHO WORKS AN UNPAID
INTERNSHIP IS ABLE TO QUALIFY.
AS MEETING CAL FOR STUDENT WORK
HOURS.
AND LASTLY REQUIRED DSS TO ISSUE
PROMISING PRACTICE DREADED USED
TO INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
FOSTER FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WILL
BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM CAL FOR
ASH.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED.
THE FOOD SECURE AND TO PURSUE
OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS HIGHER
EDUCATION.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
AND JOURNEY HOUSE INTRODUCE OUR
WITNESSES JESSE AGUILAR AND
JESSICA.
BARTHOLOMAY.
THAT WOULDN'T PLEASE SIR A GOOD
AFTERNOON A CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
OF MY NAME IS JESSE I CAN I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF JOURNEY HOUSE
OF THE CO SPONSORS.
OF A. B..
TWELVE TWENTY NINE BUT WE HAVE
WORKED WITH FORMER BOSS USED FOR
OUT OF THE LOS ANGELES IN.
A CALIFORNIA -- FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS.
PRIMARILY AS DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDERS
WE SPENT MUCH OF OUR TIME --
HELPING FOSSE USE A CREE ACTUAL
PLAN ACTION PLANS THAT WILL HELP
THEM MEET THEIR HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT.
pAND WITH A PARTICULAR EMPHASIS
ON HELPING THEM ACHIEVE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH
MENTIONED STATISTICALLY ONLY 3%
THREE OR 4% OF FOUR OR FIVE TO
THE CALIFORNIA.
GOING TO COMPLETE A COLLEGE
DEGREE.
IN FACT MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
SUMMER FOR SEASON THE STATE.
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
OUR STUDENTS FIND THEMSELVES
HAVING TO MAKE VERY DIFFICULT
LIFE DECISIONS.
DETERMINING THE PRIORITIES. TOO
OFTEN THEY HAVE TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO TO STAY IN SCHOOL OR
KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS --
TO CONTINUE TO PAY FOR CHILDCARE.
OR TO PAY OUR TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE TODAY IS
FROM SUPPORT OF AB.
TWELVE TWENTY NINE THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH TWO PRIMARY
OBJECTIVES. ONE IS TO EXPAND THE
TYPE OF WORK HOURS PERMISSIBLE.
TO QUALIFY FOR THE COVERAGE
ELIGIBILITY.
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWING NON PAID
INTERNSHIPS. TO QUALIFY FOR THE
TWENTY HOUR WORK REQUIREMENT OF
CAO FRESH.
THIS PROVIDES STUDENTS
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD WORK
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD THAT
ALIGNS WITH THEIR ACADEMIC.
AND CAREER GOALS INCREASING
THEIR CHANCES OF SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS FROM AROUND THE
STATE.
THAT WHILE WORKING MEANING FOR
INTERNSHIPS AND JOBS.
DEFINING THEMSELVES UNABLE TO
RECEIVE CONFERENCE.
GIVEN THE NARROW DEFINITION OF
WHAT MEETS THE TWENTY HOUR WORK
REQUIREMENTS. FOR EXAMPLE. ONE
STUDENT IS WORKING -- INTERNET
FOR UNDERGRAD.
AT UCLA.
AND WANTS TO WORK IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION.
SO SHE THOUGHT OUT AND IS
WORKING AN UNPAID INTERNSHIP AT
A HOSPITAL.
BUT THIS IS OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
AND FEDERAL PROGRAM
QUALIFICATIONS.
AND THEREFORE SHE'S UNABLE TO
RECEIVE THE NEED COVERAGE FOOD
SUPPORT.
THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO PROVIDE
FOOD RESOURCES FOSTER YOU
CURRENTLY RECEIVING A HOUSING
STIPEND THAT EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE ALSO KNOWN AS THE TWELFTH.
WHILE THESE MAY NOT APPLY TO
THOSE YOUTH WAS TYPING THIS PAID
AS RENT. TO THE BUILDING OWNER
OR HOUSING PROVIDED DIRECTLY.
MANY FOSTER THE RECEIVING A BIT
OF HOUSING SUPPORT DIRECTLY.
ARE INELIGIBLE FOR CALPERS.
BECAUSE OUR HOUSING STIPEND IS
PAID TO THEM DIRECTLY -- IN --
AND THEN THE USE THAT MONEY TO
PAY FOR THEIR TO THEIR HOW TO
PAY FOR THEIR HOUSING.
THIS IS THEREFORE COUNTED AS
PART OF THEIR INCOME.
WHICH PUTS THEM OVER THE INCOME
LIMIT FOR CONFERENCE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROVIDE THESE
RESOURCES TO YOUTH WITH COVERAGE
FOOD SUPPORT.
UTILIZING THE CURRENT A. B.
TWELVE STEP IN PROCESS.
ALLOCATING FUNDS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH TO COVER FOOD EXPENSES.
FORMER FOSSEY'S SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS ARE
CRUCIAL PURSUING THEIR ACADEMIC
AND CAREER GOALS.
IT IS THE ONLY SUPPORT THEY CAN
RELY ON SINCE THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE LUXURY.
OF FAMILY FOUNDATION.
BY MAKING THESE CRUCIAL
INVESTMENTS THE STATE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE ITS COMMITMENT.
AS A LEADER IN THE SOCIAL WORK.
THE LIGHTS FOSTER YOUTH.
IT IS FOR THE REASON THAT WE ARE
JUST A PART.
OF AB.
TWELVE TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JUST ABOUT THE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WERE
PROUD TO COSPONSOR THIS BILL.
I WOULD JUST A BRIEF STATEMENT
THAT -- IT'S ALWAYS SO
FRUSTRATING AS AN ANTI HUNGER
ADVOCATE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EVERYBODY AGREES THAT.
THE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND THE
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH
SHOULDN'T GO HUNGRY AND THAT
BEING HUNGRY DOESN'T HELP THEM
ACHIEVE THEIR ACADEMIC
PROFESSIONAL OR LIFE OR HEALTH
GOALS.
AND IT MAKES US LOOK BAD AS A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THESE ARE
OUR CHILDREN.
AND YET THE POLICY OF BARRIERS --
TO THIS POPULATION RECEIVING
CALPERS ARE SO.
DIRE -- AND WE JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE ARE ARE CO SPONSORS
COMING TO US AND SAYING.
WE UNDERSTAND THESE LOOK
INTRACTABLE BUT WHAT CAN WE DO
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR SAYING.
THIS IS GONNA BE TOUGH WE'RE
GOING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S STAFF AND THE
CHAIRMAN WOMAN FOR HELPING US
MAKE THE BILL BETTER TO GET
THERE.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE BILL
THAT WE'RE PRESENTING TODAY AND
JR I BUILT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WHERE SECONDS ALSO WE HAVE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND STRONG SUPPORT?
THANK YOU.
THE UNIVERSITY POLICY MANAGER
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SEAN TIAS RUN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING EXPERIMENT
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ENTER SHANE CALIFORNIA CESSATION
OF FOOD BANKS DRUGS PART THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TO THE AN
INDEFINITE CHILDREN DOWN SUPPORT.
THANKS THANK YOU.
GENEREX ROAD WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JOIN THE CORRECT CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER GIBSON.
I GUESS THIS ME.
YOU KNOW I WANT -- TO ONE JUST
SIMPLY SAY TO THE OFFICE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
MUCH NEEDED PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BEFORE US -- I THINK IS A
TRAVESTY -- WHEN YOU HAVE A
FOSTER KIDS GOING HUNGRY -- WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROVIDE -- FOOD FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS 45% OF THE THE
PEOPLE OF MY DISH FOR ELIGIBLE
CAL FOR ASH -- AND NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF IT -- WHEN I WAS
FIRST ELECTED ME MY FAMILY TOOK
ONE A LOT OF CALIFORNIA'S AND
TRY TO LIVE OFF OF IT FOR A WEEK
WHICH MEANS WHEN I'M UP HERE?
WHATEVER -- MY SHARE WAS IF IT
RAN OUT I COULDN'T GO AND DRINK
COFFEE AND IS DIFFICULT EVEN FOR
FAMILY ON CAL FOR ASH TO MAKE
ENDS MEET.
AND SO TO LOOK OUT OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY WHICH IS
OUR FOSTER YOU -- I'LL SAY THIS
AND CLOSE HAD OPPORTUNITY TO GO --
TO IRON WOOD PRISON -- MEN'S
PRISON.
AND EVERY MALE THAT I SPOKE.
TO THEY WERE IN THE FOSTER
SYSTEM.
AND WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BREAK THAT CYCLE WE HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVERSE THE CURSE --
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY CHILD
WHO'S A FOSTER CHILD HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO FINISH SCHOOL AND
GOING TO COLLEGE AND I BELIEVE
THAT THE WORK WE'RE DOING HERE
TO STARTS HERE -- IS IN FACT
WORKING TOWARDS THAT PARTICULAR
IN AND SO I WOULD LOVE TO BE
PART.
AS A CALL AFTER YOU CONSIDER ME
AS A CAR FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK THIS BILL AFTER READING IS
TAX IS MOVING A RIGHT DIRECTION
SPECIALLY BUT SOMEONE.
WHO HAS TAKEN UP THE MATTER TO
WORK SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE -- ON
BEHALF OF THEM BEING A VOICE FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE AND THAT'S
ARE YOU FOR IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON IS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY.
ONLY 3% OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH ARE
GRADUATING WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE WERE FAILING.
ABSOLUTELY FAILING WE'VE GOT TO
FIND A WAY WHEN WE PUT TOGETHER
THE BUDGET.
WHICH IS A STATEMENT OF OUR
VALUES THAT WE FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND THE MONEY
IN SUCH A WAY THAT WE DO TAKE
CARE THE MOST VULNERABLE.
I DO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS.
BILL FORWARD.
WE HAVE NO MOTION YET.
MOVE.
AND I SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- YOU
GUYS SAID IT ALL -- APPRECIATE
HAVING HAVE YOU AS A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I JUST WOULD SAY ONE
LAST THING I THINK.
GIVEN THE CURRENT MOMENT THAT
WERE IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE
STATE RIGHT NOW WHEN WE LOOK AT
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES FACING US
WITH REGARD TO THE WEALTH GAP IN
INCOME INEQUALITY IN THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES AND ALL THESE THINGS.
IT MANIFESTS ITSELF IN THIS
ISSUE AND SO WE HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN RIGHT NOW IT
IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO
STRENGTHEN THAT SOCIAL SAFETY
NET.
AND IT STARTS WITH BILLS LIKE
THIS SO I JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT PLEASE TAKE
ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES I RAMOS I'D
MATHIS.
BERMAN CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIVES AND I AM MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
IF.
TWO TWO ZERO IT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MS RUBIO.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN WITH
ITEM NUMBER -- THREE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN AB ONE SIX SEVEN YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN
ENACT THAT WOULD GREATLY
INCREASE ACCESS TO QUALITY CHILD
CHILD CARE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL OF THEIR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
AS A CO CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BLUE RIBBON AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION POT COMMITTEE AS
FORMED -- AND IS A FORMER
CLASSROOM TEACHER EDUCATION HAS
BEEN A LIFELONG PASSION FOR ME.
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY ONLY 9% OF
LOW INCOME INFANTS AND TODDLERS
AGES ZERO TWO THREE ARE ENROLLED
IN SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE.
EVEN IF YOU'RE FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS WITH
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT SERVICES
THAT HAVE THE GREATEST POSITIVE
IMPACT ON LOCAL INCOME BABIES.
IN MY DISTRICT 93% OF INFANTS
AND TODDLERS WHO ARE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE ARDEN UNSERVED.
EDUCATION IS THE BEST TOOL THAT
WE HAVE TO FIGHT LONG TERM
CYCLES OF POVERTY AND TWO OF UP
LIVE COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS WHY I HAVE INTRODUCED
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL HELP
CLOSE THE EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY GAP.
FACING OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN BY
IN STRENGTHENING AND EXPANDING
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
AS WE EXPAND OUR INVESTMENT IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD WE SHOULD ENSURE
THAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO TRULY
HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS.
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO SUPPORT
THEIR BRAINDEVELOPMENT SOCIAL
SKILLS AND KATE KINDERGARTEN
READINESS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT HIGH QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS THAT
START EARLIER IN A CHILD'S LIFE
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
WE NEED TO HOLD OURSELVES TO A
HIGH STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO
MAKING SURE CHILDREN WHO FACE
THE BIGGEST BARRIERS. TO
OPPORTUNITY ARE HIGH IN QUITE
QUALITY NURTURING AND EDUCATION
ARE EARNING LEARNING PROGRAMS.
AS THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
REPORT HIGHLIGHTS WE ALSO NEED
ECT PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
AND WE CAN BUILD ON A PROVEN.
BUILT ON PROVEN TO GENERATIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDE FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT HELP
FAMILIES WITH THE RESOURCES AND
PARENTAL PARENTS' AND SKILLS
THEY NEED TO HELP THEIR CHILDREN --
TO SUCCEED.
AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THE
EXISTING CHILD CARE CENTERS AND
FAMILY.
CHILDCARE HOMES TO RETIRE
STANDARDS BASED ON THE PREVENT
EARLY TO HEAD START MODEL.
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT FAMILIES.
FAMILY SUPPORT WORKERS TO HELP
PARENTS HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENING BETTER TRAIN TEACHERS
AND CONNECTIONS TO WELL CHILD
HEALTH AND DENTAL CARE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THIS KIND OF
COMPREHENSIVE WHOLE CHILD WHOLE
FAMILY APPROACH TO CHILD
DEVELOPMENT HAS THE BIGGEST
IMPACT ON CHECK CHILDREN IN
POVERTY.
MY BILL ALSO PROPOSES EXPANDING
QUALITY FAMILY CENTERED CHILD
CARE TO TWENTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL INFANTS AND TODDLERS
LIVING IN HIGH NEED COMING
COMMUNITIES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR NEW SOME.
AS WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
MORE SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE SLOTS
FOR CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
I HAVE MY SPONSORS HERE AND
SUPPORTERS HERE WITH -- TO
TESTIFY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS A SURPRISE FOR
NOW I HAVE TWO CHILDREN WHO ARE
ATTENDING KIDDING THOSE CUTS
AMOUNT CHILD CARE CENTER IN
OAKLAND.
MY DAUGHTER NOT THE LIST FOR
YEARS OLD AND MY SAN JUAN CARLOS
IS TWO YEARS OLD.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
WANT MORE PARENTS.
AND YOUNG CHILDREN TO HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS
LIKE WE HAVE.
MY TWO CHILDREN HAVE BENEFITTED
IMMENSELY FROM THE EARLY HEAD
START PROGRAM THE CENTER OPEN
TWO YEARS AGO.
AND I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
OWN ONE THAT THE LA RIGHT AWAY
BEFORE KIDDING GO OPENED.
MY TWO CHILDREN WEARING A
LICENSED HOME DAY CARE FOR A
WEEK HOWEVER.
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT AT THAT
THEY CARE.
WITH MY SUB ONE CARLOS THAT
RESULTED IN A HOSPITAL STAY.
DUE TO SUB DROVE HIM TO MUCH AND
MULTIPLE REYNAUD HEMORRHAGES.
IT SHOOK MY CONFIDENCE AND I
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE I COULD TRUST.
ANYONE ELSE WITH MY SON.
SO I QUIT MY JOB. TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF MYSELF.
NOT VALID WAS FLOURISHING I CAN
BIGELOW AND MAKING BIG STRIDES
AND HER DEVELOPMENT.
I ALSO DEVELOP WONDERFUL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE TEACHERS.
AND SAW FIRSTHAND THE SUPPORT
AND CARE THAT THEY PROVIDED
EVERY CHILD.
IT WAS THIS THAT GAVE ME THE
ABILITY TO TRUST.
AND ANOTHER PROGRAM TO TAKE CARE
OF WE GOT A LOS.
I WROTE HIM WHEN HE WAS
SEVENTEEN MONTHS OLD AND I WAS
ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK.
BOTH CLINTON AND ONE CARLOS WERE
ENROLLED.
IN THE REGIONAL CENTER OF THE
EAST BAY FOR SPEECH AND EARLY
INTERVENTION THERAPY.
KIDDING ALL HAVE CELL BOTH MY
CHILDREN.
GROW AND LEARN MORE EVERY DAY
BESIDES THEIR THERAPIES.
NOT VALID CAN NOW CREATE
SENTENCES WITH MORE THAN ONE
WORD AND HAS ALSO WRITING HER
FIRST AND LAST NAME.
AND TOLD TO HOLD SHE IS.
JUAN CARLOS DEVELOP A LOT SINCE
HE STARTED THE PROGRAM.
BEFORE HE WOULD FALL OR TRIP A
LOT.
AND ONE NOT HAVE VERY ARE VERY
GOOD EYE CONTACT.
NOW HE REPEATS WORDS INTERACT
MORE WITH HIS CLASSMATES AND
TEACHERS.
THE SUPPORT OFFERED BY TEACHERS
AND FAMILY ADVOCATES HAS BEEN
AMAZING BOTH IN TERMS OF HELPING
MY CHILDREN DEVELOP AND
PROVIDING ME WITH THE SKILLS AND
RESOURCES.
TO SUPPORT.
MY KIDS INCLUDING HELP WITH
PLACES TO LIVE.
THE TEACHERS ALSO HOPE ME WITH
TIPS SO I CAN WEAR THE THINGS
THEY LEARN AT SCHOOL AT HOME.
I CALL IT SCHOOL BECAUSE KIDDING --
OFFERS SO MUCH MORE THAN JUST
ACRE.
IT IS A PLACE FOR THEM TO LEARN
TO SHARE AND INTERACT WITH
OTHERS.
MY KIDS LOVE GOING AND I WANT
THEM TO ASSOCIATE THEIR
EXPERIENCES WITH SCHOOL SO THAT
WHEN SCHOOL STARTS.
THOUGH HOW POSITIVE EXPENSE
EXPENSE EXPECTATIONS AND WILL BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THEIR LOVE.
OF LEARNING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WOULD DO
WITHOUT THE KIDDING -- CENTER
KNOWING THAT MY CHILDREN ARE
SAFE SUPPORTED.
AND LEARNING IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
ME AND MY FAMILY.
KIDDING WAS MY CHILDREN SECOND
HOME THEY SPEND THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR TIME AT SCHOOL.
AND HAVE BUILT STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
TEACHERS I URGE YOU TO EXPAND
HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS. FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS TO MORE
FAMILY THING CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA CRAWLEY AND I AM
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FOR
ZERO TO THREE IN CALIFORNIA.
ZERO TO THREE IS A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WHOSE
MISSION IS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
BABIES AND TODDLERS HAVE A
STRONG START IN LIFE.
IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
THAT WE OPENED AN OFFICE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A CO SPONSOR
OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN
INCREASING ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE FOR
VULNERABLE INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION SYSTEM LEAVES TOO
MANY LOW INCOME BABIES AND
TODDLERS BEHIND.
IT'S JUST 9% OF CALIFORNIA'S LOW
INCOME INFANTS AND TODDLERS THAT
ARE ENROLLED IN SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE.
EVEN FEWER FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS
TO THE HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS WITH
THAT HAVE THE GREATEST POSITIVE
INCOME IMPACT.
ON LOW INCOME BABIES.
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE DEPENDS ON
QUALITY AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE.
QUALITY CHILD CARE FEET THE
BABY'S GROWING BRAIN.
BUILDING THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTS AND LEARNING
NECESSARY FOR THEM TO THRIVE AS
ADULTS.
IT'S THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF
LIFE THAT ARE SO CRITICAL.
THIS IS WHEN THE BRAIN
CONNECTIONS ARE FORMING AT A
RATE OF MORE THAN ONE MILLION
PER SECOND.
POSITIVE INTERACTIONS WITH
NURTURING CARE GIVERS.
REINFORCE THESE CONNECTIONS
CREATING A STRONG FOUNDATION.
QUALITY CHILDCARE PREPARES
BABIES FOR FUTURE LEARNING AND
SUCCESS.
IT'S IN THESE HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS THAT
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO HAVE
ENHANCED VOCABULARY.
HAVE MORE SOPHISTICATED
ATTENTION AND MEMORY SKILLS AND
GET ALONG BETTER WITH THEIR
PEERS.
HOW THE SINGLE MOM OF TWO
DAUGHTERS I KNOW FIRST HAND?
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO ACCESS
AFFORDABLE QUALITY CHILDCARE?
MY DAUGHTERS WERE RECIPIENTS OF
HIGH QUALITY SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE THAT PROVIDED ME THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO FINISH COLLEGE
AND GO TO WORK.
BECAUSE OF THIS OPPORTUNITY I
BELIEVE I HAVE RAISE TWO AMAZING
YOUNG ADULTS.
WHO WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES?
MANY MANY MORE FAMILIES WHO NEED
IT DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR BABIES AND
TODDLERS HAVE A STRONG START IN
LIFE.
AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN WILL HELP
CLOSE THE EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY GAP.
BY STRENGTHENING AND EXPANDING
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS FOR INFANTS
AND TODDLERS BASED ON THE
EFFECTIVE.
EARLY HEAD START MODEL.
PROVIDERS WILL RECEIVE FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CHILD
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT TO BETTER
SUPPORT -- TO TRAIN TEACHERS
STRENGTHENED FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES ANOFFER DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS AND PROVIDE
CONNECTIONS TO CHILD HEALTH CARE
AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND OTHER COMMUNITY RESOURCES.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE AND
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT SERVICES
TO TWENTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
LOW INCOME INFANTS AND TODDLERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
HI MICHELLE STOLE PERMITS KEEP
FROM GETTING GO PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
Q..
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
WHERE SECONDS ALL SOME BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
ON I AM COMMITTEES WITH EARLY
EDGE CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JANICE CAN ALAN CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN INS CO FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- GRAPPLE
GIVE IT A MINUTE ON EDUCATION
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ON A HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS I THINK
ANYTHING THAT WE DO.
FOR THE CHILD CARE YOU'RE RIGHT
ZERO THREE WE HEAR IT WE HEAR WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
AND MAKE SURE THAT TO GOOD
QUALITY CHILDCARE IS PROVIDED.
WOULD YOU LIKE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER GIPSON SECOND BY
MYSELF WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF SITTING WITH YOU ON THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WE HEARD THE SAME
MESSAGE OVER AND OVER AGAIN HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE.
IS WHAT WHAT ARE OUR PORTS
FAMILIES NEED -- WE TALK ABOUT
LIFTING FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
AND THE INVESTMENT HAS TO BE IN
CHILD CARE BECAUSE THE NUMBER --
ONE HINDRANCE AS WE WOULD HAVE
HEARD HERE WAS -- HIGH QUALITY
CHILD CARE I ALSO AM A MOM OF
TWO AND YOU KNOW I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE -- HIGH QUALITY --
NOT NON SUBSIDIZED -- CHILD CARE
AND AS A TEACHER AT THAT TIME I
WAS BLESSED ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THE SUMMERS OFF WITH MY
CHILDREN AND I HAD YOU KNOW THE
BENEFITS OF BEING -- ON THE
TEACHER CALENDAR I HAD THE YOU
KNOW -- HOLIDAYS OFF AND
CHRISTMAS OFF IT BUT NOT
EVERYBODY HAS THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND SO FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO GIVE
BACK IN THIS WAY IS IMPORTANT --
WE AS A FORMER TEACHER I CAN
TELL YOU THE BIG DIFFERENCE IT
MAKES AND IN A CHILD'S LIFE TO
HAVE THE SUPPORT AND THE
FOUNDATION WHEN THEY START
KINDERGARTEN SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
I NOT ONLY THE TIME THAT WE
SPENT TOGETHER IN THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION BUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD I
KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG LEFT.
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT WITH THE
SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUES AND THE
GOVERNOR'S WILLINGNESS TO TO
INVEST IN.
THIS TYPE OF A PROGRAM -- WILL
HELP AS I'M ADVOCATING EVERY DAY
AT SOLVE OUR MY SPONSORS AND I
HAVE FAMILIES AND PARENTS THAT
ARE ADVOCATING AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN COUNT ON YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL.
BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND I APPRECIATE AGAIN
THE TIME THAT -- THIS IS BEING
GIVE THEN BUT I KNOW THAT YOU
ALSO HAVE YOUR OWN PRIORITIES --
WHICH WOULD CONTINUE THE AFTER --
THREE AFTER -- FOR CARE AND I
THINK IF WE ALL PUT OUR BRAINS
TOGETHER NO PUN INTENDED IF WE
PUT OUR BRAINS TOGETHER I THINK
WE CAN MAKE -- EIGHTY SOME
SUBSTANTIAL GAINS IN THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION ARENA WHICH
WOULD DEFINITELY LEFT WHAT WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT WILL LIFT OUR
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY AND
EDUCATION IS THE KEY WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
IT HAPPENED FOR MYSELF -- AND
FOR MY FAMILY AND I THINK THAT
IF WE OFFER THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE AND WE CAN PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS AND
MAKE SURE THAT.
FAMILIES ARE UPLIFTED AND OUR
TAKING OUT OF POVERTY THROUGH
EDUCATION SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I DO WANT TO THANK YOU AND I
HOPE LONG GODLESS IS DOING GREAT
AND THRIVING ALONG WITH THAT.
HE ACTUALLY IS THANKS TO THE
HIGH QUALITY CHILD CARE THAT HE
IS AN AL ONE HE IS MUCH MORE AND
HE IS.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF OTHER TEACHERS
WOULD TELL ME THAT YOU KNOW.
HE PROBABLY WENT.
NOT BE ABLE TO DO A LOT OF
THINGS THAT HE'S DOING NOW.
WHERE APPLAUD YOU AS A MOM? FOR
BEING WILLING TO COME UP HERE
IT'S NOT EASY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING BAD THAT'S HAPPENED.
BUT FOR YOU TO BE WILLING TO
COME HERE TO GIVE TESTIMONY.
AND TO REMIND US HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS SO THAT OTHER KIDS DON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
RIGHT YES HI RES I AM MATHIS
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN STONE. TWO ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THAT
ONE ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
FIVE EIGHTY THREE NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO THEIR IN PRESENTING
AB THREE NINETY FIVE THE FOSTER
YOUTH SAFETY ACT WHICH WILL
STRENGTHENING INVESTIGATIONS OF
ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
OF CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM.
AB THREE NINETY FIVE WILL CREATE
TIMELINES BY WHEN CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS MUST BE COMPLETED
WHEN CONDUCTING THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
THIS BILL COMES AS A RESULT OF
AN AUDIT CONDUCTED BY THE OFFICE
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THAT DISCOVERED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WAS NOT ALWAYS.
PROPERLY RECORDING INVESTIGATING
AND RESOLVING CASES OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT.
IN FACT THIS REPORT NOTED THAT
IN SOME COMPLAINTS CASES
APPROXIMATELY.
OF IN THAT IN SOME COMPLAINTS
CASES TOOK APPROXIMATELY TWO TO
FIFTEEN MONTHS.
I IN WHICH THERE WAS NO ACTIVITY
NOTED IN. TO INDICATE THAT THE
COMPLAINTS WERE BEING ACTIVELY
INVESTIGATED THAT'S TOO LONG.
IN FACT THIS REPORT NOTED THAT
IN SOME.
A COMPLAINT CASES APPROX I'M
SORRY.
MOVE ON IN ADDITION THE REPORT
ALSO NOTED THAT SOME OF THE MOST
SERIOUS COMPLAINTS INVOLVING
SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL ABUSE TOOK
AN AVERAGE OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS. TO BE COMPLETED AND
WE'RE NOT ALWAYS PROPERLY CROSS
REPORTED.
THESE OUR FINDINGS THAT I DO NOT
TAKE LIGHTLY AND I KNOW THAT
NONE OF US HERE DO.
WE HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION TO
THESE CHILDREN WHO HAVE ALREADY
EXPERIENCE UNTHINKABLE HARDSHIPS
BY BEING RIPPED AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES.
ALLOWING CHILDREN TO REMAIN IN
POTENTIALLY UNSAFE CONDITIONS
WHILE UNDER THE STATE'S CARE IS
SIMPLY WRONG.
BY ESTABLISHING THESE CRITICAL
STANDARDS AND PROTOCOLS BY WHICH
THE COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION AND LOCAL INVESTIGATORS
MUST ABIDE BY WHEN CONDUCTING
INVESTIGATIONS OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT.
I AM GLAD IN OUT OF HOME CARE WE
ARE PROTECTING CHILDREN FROM
EXPERIENCING FURTHER HARM AND
TRAUMA AT THE HANDS OF THOSE
ENTRUSTED TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ARE MEMBERS
FROM TO CO SPONSOR TO CO
SPONSORS OF AB THREE NINETY FIVE
WHO CAN FURTHER ELABORATE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL.
SARAH PORTER FOUNDER AND CEO OF
PHENOMENAL PHENOMENAL PHENOMENAL
FAMILIES AND TRAUMA INFORMED
SYSTEM SPECIALISTS.
WITH BUT CHADWICK CENTER JULIE
MCCORMICK POLICY ASSOCIATE OF
THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER AND I
DON'T HAVE THE NAME OF THE THIRD
PERSON.
ALL RIGHT YOUR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON RAY
AS AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEECH TODAY
MY NAME IS SERRA POTTER AND I AM
THE FOUNDER AND CEO PHENOMENAL
FAMILIES.
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BASED
OUT OF SAN DIEGO THAT SERVES
PREGNANT AND PARENTING YOU COULD
EXPERIENCE FOSTER CARE.
I AM ALSO A NATIONAL EXPERT ON
TRAUMA INFORMED TROUBLE FOR
SYSTEMS AND A LOAN NOT A FOSTER
CARE IN THE VERY SAME SYSTEM
THAT I NOW WORK AND I AM HERE
TODAY TO STRESS THE IMPORTANCE
OF TIMELY AND QUALITY
INVESTIGATIONS OF MALTREATMENT
OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN CARE.
THIS PAST SUMMER I WAS ASKED BY
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO SERVE ON A
SPECIAL WORKING GROUP. TO
EXAMINE CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
FOLLOWING SEVERAL HIGH PROFILE
CASES.
OF TWO TWIN BROTHERS TO BEEN
SEXUALLY CHRONICALLY OR
CRITICALLY SEXUALLY ABUSED BY
THEIR FOSTER FATHER.
DESPITE THE BROTHERS REPEATEDLY
DISCLOSING THE ABUSE TO THEIR
SOCIAL WORKER AND MORE THAN A
DOZEN REPORTS TO THE AGENCY BY
OTHER ADULTS ON THE CHILDREN'S
LIVES THEIR CLAIMS WERE NEVER
ADEQUATELY INVESTIGATED AND THE
BOYS ARE MADE IN THE HOME AT THE
MERCY OF THEIR ABUSER.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THESE TWO TWIN
BOYS RESONATE WITH ME ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL?
JUST TEN YEARS PRIOR AT THE AGE
OF THIRTEEN MY OWN BROTHER WAS
VIOLENTLY SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN
A GROUP HOME.
HIS DISCLOSURE TO GROUP HOME
STOP WAS WHAT WAS ABOUT WITH GOT
UP WITH WAS MET WITH SKEPTICISM
AND WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS AN
ATTITUDE THAT THE ASSAULT WAS
SOMEHOW WANTED OR WARRANTED
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN LABELED A
DIFFICULT CHILD.
HE HAD TO RECOUNT WHAT HAPPENED
TO HIM OVER A DOZEN TIMES TO
COMPLETE STRANGERS HOPING
SOMEONE WOULD BELIEVE HIM.
INSTEAD OF BEING MATT WITH
COMPASSION AND TREATED LIKE A
VICTIM OF A VIOLENT ASSAULT HE
WAS SENT BACK TO THE SAME GROUP
HOME. TO FACE THE SHAME AND
HUMILIATION OF WHAT HAD HAPPENED
TO HIM WHAT THE VARIOUS AGENCIES
WORKED ON THEIR INVESTIGATIONS.
FOLLOWING MY BROTHER'S ASSAULT
WE WERE TOLD THAT CHILD WELFARE
WOULD DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER TO ENSURE THAT SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS WOULDN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
YET HERE I AM YEARS LATER.
WITH MORE EXAMPLES OF HOW
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE
SYSTEMATICALLY FAILED CHILDREN
IN OUR CARE PARTICULARLY THOSE
INVOLVING YOUTH CLUB AND LABEL
DIFFICULT.
WHO HAVE BEEN QUOTE UNQUOTE HAVE
A QUOTE UNQUOTE CREDIBILITY
ISSUES OR WHO MAY HAVE BEEN SEEN
AS TRYING TO GET BACK AT THEIR
FOSTER PARENTS BROTHER SOCIAL
WORKER?
THE TRAUMA THAT WE EXPERIENCE
AND FOSTER CARE IS A BURDEN THAT
WE CARRY WITH US FOR THE REST OF
OUR LIVES.
WE CAN EASE THAT BURDEN BY
ENSURING THAT NO CHILD HAS TO
PROVE THE HARM THAT THEY HAD
BEEN SUBJECTED.
TO INSTEAD WE CAN UTILIZE
TRAINED INTERVIEWERS AT THE
CHILD ADVOCACY ADVOCACY CENTERS.
AND TIMELY WELL COORDINATED
INVESTIGATIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO KEEP CHILDREN SAFE AND
BEGIN THE HEALING PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH SCREENS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JULIE
MCCORMICK POLICY ASSOCIATE AT
THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
CALIFORNIA WE ARE A NONPROFIT
LAW FIRM THAT REPRESENTS OVER
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN.
AND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE IN LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER
COUNTIES.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A SPONSOR OF
AB THREE NINETY FIVE WHICH WILL
ENSURE AN APPROPRIATE RESPONSE
WHEN THERE IS AN ALLEGATION THAT
A CHILD IN FOSTER CARE.
HAS BEEN THE VICTIM OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT.
IN OUR PRACTICE WE SEE FAR TOO
MANY OF OUR CHILD CLIENTS
SUFFERING FROM ABUSE AND NEGLECT
IN THE VERY HOMES INTENDED TO
PROTECT THEM FROM ABUSIVE
FAMILIES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY FAR TOO OFTEN
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
ARE NOT RESPONDED TO
APPROPRIATELY BY THE VERY SYSTEM
INTENDED TO PROTECT THESE
CHILDREN.
THEIR FAILURES TO REPORT
ALLEGATIONS FAILURES TO
INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS AND
FAILURES TO PROTECT CHILDREN
EVEN AFTER SUBSTANTIATING
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
FOR EXAMPLE STILL SEE
REPRESENTED A YOUNG GIRL WHO FOR
MANY YEARS WAS A VICTIM OF
SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL ABUSE BY HER
FOSTER FATHER.
SHE DISCLOSE THIS ABUSE TO A
TEACHER WHO APPROPRIATE REPORTED
THE ALLEGATION TO THE CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY.
HOWEVER THIS INITIAL REPORT WAS
NOT CROSS REPORTED TO LICENSING
AN INVESTIGATION DID NOT IN SU.
AFTER A SECOND REPORT WAS MADE A
LICENSING INVESTIGATION DID
BEGAN BUT IT CONTINUED FOR YEARS.
OUR CLIENTS OWN ATTORNEY WAS NOT
AWARE OF THE ALLEGATION NOR WAS
SHE MADE AWARE OF THE PENDING
INVESTIGATION UNTIL IT WAS
REVEALED DURING A TRIAL ON AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT ISSUE.
THE CHILD WAS REMOVED FROM THE
HOME BY A COURT ORDER.
SADLY AS YOU HAVE HEARD FROM THE
OTHER WITNESS THIS SAME
SITUATION.
THIS IS WHY THIS LEGISLATION IS
SO CRUCIAL. EIGHTY THREE NINETY
FIVE IS INTENDED TO RESOLVE THE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS AND HELP
PROTECT THE CHILDREN YOUTH OUR
STATE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
KEEP SAFE.
IT DOES SOBRE REQUIRING THAT AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATOR
CONDUCTING QUERY INTO A REVIEW
SOME OF INTO REPORT OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT.
THEREBY REDUCING THE POSSIBILITY
THAT REPORTS FROM A TRAUMATIZED
CHILD WILL BE DISMISSED.
AND ALLOW THE INVESTIGATION OF
FOCUS MORE ON OBSERVABLE FACTS
THAN ON PAST IMPRESSIONS.
YOU WERE A CRIER THE COSTA CROSS
REPORTING OF ALLEGATIONS BETWEEN
LICENSING AGENCIES AND THE CHILD
WHAT.
CHILD WELFARE AGENCY REGARDLESS
OF THE TYPE OF FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT CHILD LIVES IN.
AND FINALLY PUTTING INTO PLACE
CLEAR GUIDELINES ABOUT LICENSING
INVESTIGATIONS ONE SURE EVERY
ALLEGATION OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
IS RESPONDED TO AND INVESTIGATED
APPROPRIATELY.
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM ARE UNDER THE CARE
AND CUSTODY OF THE STATE.
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY SHIELD
THEM FROM FURTHER ABUSE AND
TRAUMA AND THE LAW MUST MANDATE
A SENSIBLE COMMONSENSE APPROACH
TO COLLECTING INFORMATION ON
ALLEGATIONS.
OF MALTREATMENT BY THOSE
ENTRUSTED TO THE CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN.
CLC IS PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS
LEGISLATION AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
LET'S.
MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
WE'RE ALSO CO SPONSORS ON THE
BILL AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
HOW ABOUT THE LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHAT'S THE SEVERAL JOHN BURNETT
GETS YOUTH STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GENEREX READ WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS AND
SUPPORT.
IS THE INTERNET NO CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS AN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND.
WORKING CLOTHES.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE.
FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE ON ON THIS
VERY DIFFICULT -- ISSUE AS WE
HEARD.
THEIR CHILDREN ARE DEPENDING ON
US TO TAKE CARE OF THEM AND IF
WE DON'T PUT SYSTEMS IN PLACE
THAT ARE GOING TO PROTECT THEM.
THEN WHAT ARE WE DOING -- WE'VE
HEARD THIS TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THESE ARE THE VULNERABLE KIDS
THAT -- DEPEND ON OUR HELP AGAIN
AS A FORMER SCHOOL TEACHER I CAN
TELL YOU IS HOW MANY KIDS CAME.
AND THEY'RE ONLY -- FORM OF
SAFETY WAS OUR CLASSROOMS AND I
DON'T WANT THAT TO BE THE CASE I
TALKED ABOUT -- THE ABILITY TO
BE OFF IN THE SUMMERS AND AND
FOR HOLIDAYS WITH MY OWN
CHILDREN FOR THESE KIDS IS IT'S
GOT TO BE TERRORIZING TO BE OFF
IN THE SUMMER.
AND IN THE HOLIDAYS BECAUSE NOW
THEY GET TO SPEND MORE TIME IN
THE PLACES THAT THEY'RE NOT
BEING TAKEN CARE OF IF SCHOOL IS
THE ONLY -- SAFE HAVEN THEY HAVE
THEN I WOULD NOT BE WANT TO BE
IN THEIR SHOES SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE TAKE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
RAY YES AYE REYES AYE MATHIS
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON MAIENSCHEIN
STONE.
VOTERS TO ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
RECORD OPEN FOR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
MISS BETWEEN THE HOURS.
YOU ARE PRESENTING ON ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE AB.
ELEVEN NINETY NINE YES HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PRESENTING A DISTRICT BELL
RELATED TO THE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENT CENTER A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN ACRES STATE PROPERTY
LOCATED IN THE SEVENTY FOURTH.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
COSTA MESA.
I'VE FOR CONTEXT LET ME JUST
PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF BACKGROUND
THE FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTS AND
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WAS FIRST
OPENED IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE TO
SERVE PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
AND INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
YOUR VIEW IS RUN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES DDS IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF MOVING THE REMAINING
SEVENTY RESIDENTS TO SMALLER
COMMUNITY GROUP HOMES.
AND THIS MOVE IS PART OF A
BROADER STRATEGIC SHIFT ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON HOW
BEST TO DELIVERED THE SERVICE
SAYS.
ON THIS TRANSITION WILL BE
COMPLETE BY THE END OF TWENTY
NINETEEN WHEN FAIRVIEW IS
EXPECTED. TO BEGIN CLOSURE.
NOT SURPRISINGLY WITH A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN ACRE SITE IN THE
HEART OF ORANGE COUNTY THERE ARE
NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS NINE
FAIRVIEW WITH KEEN INTEREST.
AND AB ONE ELEVEN NINETY NINE
SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT IF MORE
THAN ONE STATE AGENCY INDICATES
AN INTEREST IN THE FAIRVIEW
PROPERTY.
DID YES WILL BE REQUIRED TO HOLD
A PUBLIC HEARING TO SEE
COMMUNITY INPUT BEFORE I
TRANSFER TO ANY STATE AGENCY CUT
A CAR.
THE FIVE MICHAEL AND IS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A PROCESS
THAT GETS COMMUNITY INPUT AS
PART OF THE CLOSURE AND
TRANSITION.
A SIMILAR PROCESS -- WAYS WAS
TAKEN WHEN THE SNOW MAY
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER CLOSED IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND THE DEED AT
DDS UNDERWENT A THOROUGH PROCESS
IF COMMUNITY REVIEW IN
CONSULTATION WHICH WAS VERY WELL
RECEIVED BY THE COMMUNITY AND
PROVED TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE.
SO AS I SAID MICHAEL IS TO
ENSURE THAT IT A SIMILAR PROCESS
OCCURS HERE WITH FAIRVIEW AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE SUPPORT.
OF THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SECOND.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE WERE FIRST AND A SECOND
PLEASE TAKE ROLE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE IT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
RIGHT YES HI RAY S. I'D MATHIS
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN STONE. TWO ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE RECORD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
CAME OUT I'M SURE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO PRESENT [inaudible]
AB.
SIX A BILL WHICH CREATES THE
BRANCH OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION INCREASING THE
CAPACITY.
AND GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR ALL
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
THIS GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE CAME
AS A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
SPEAKERS OF BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION.
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
THIS COMMISSION WORKED
DILIGENTLY FOR TWO YEARS AT
ASSESSING ALL ASPECTS.
OF THE VERY COMPLEX EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION STRUCTURE WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE AFTER PREPARED A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT.
WITH A LONG ARRAY OF PLANS TO
EXPAND EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
FROM CHILD CARE TO PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS WITH PROPOSALS BY
EVERYONE FROM THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION.
THE GOVERNOR.
THE MULTITUDE OF LEGISLATORS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE ELEVATE
EXISTING GOVERNANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THE COMING INFLUX OF
PROGRAM EXPANSION.
THIS NEW BRANCH WILL HELP
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IT'S SUCCEEDING WELL
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
CONTINUE
STRUCTURES FOR RAPIDLY
EXPANDING AREAS OF EDUCATION
RATHER THAN REACTIVE CAN INSURE
THAT THE PLANS SET FORTH BY THE
GOVERNOR.
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION AND
OUR COLLEAGUES ARE SUCCESSFULLY
ADMINISTERED FROM THE START.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS THE GREATEST
EQUALIZER.
AND THE CALIFORNIA IT SHOULD
PROVIDE FOR FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
BRANCH OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WILL ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THESE SO SICK SO CHAU.
SOCIO ECONOMICALLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY TRANSFORMATIVE
PROGRAMS IN A COORDINATED AND
EFFICIENT MANNER.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON DONIS NARINDER
WITH THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER -- OUR PRESIDENT CEO WAS
INVOLVED IN THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
MAKE A POSITION BUT WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT --
MAGNENTIUS PARENT VOICES A
FELLOW BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
AND WE SUPPORT.
JOHN CHILDREN WITH THE ALLIES
FOR CHILDREN DRESS FOR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERIN GABLE BY THE FIRST TYPE
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T YET HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE AUTHOR'S
WORK ON THIS TO ELEVATE THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD SUPPORT WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AND TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE MORE
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT THE FIELD
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM COMMITTEES WITH EARLIER
CALIFORNIANS A PART OF THE BILL.
DOES THE GHETTO AT THE TEL
CAROLINE'S OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
MOTION THAT I CAN SECOND.
HOW MANY I'M OF THE BILL?
I KNOW SECOND AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ONLY ALL
COMMITTEE MEETINGS FOR THE CZ.
YES.
OKAY -- BUT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND IF WE CAN HAVE A ROLL
CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RANTS.
AYE REYES AYE MATHIS
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
OKAY TWO ZERO BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND YOUR
NEXT BILL.
THANK YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT.
AB.
ONE NINETY FOUR I'M OF THE BILL.
I'LL SECOND THAT -- ANYONE WHO
WISHES IT TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TO PRESENT AB
ONE NINETY FOUR I AM PROUD TO
FIGHT FOR ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. TO BE
UTILIZED TO FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE SLOTS AS PART OF AB.
ONE NINETY FOUR WELL ESTABLISHED
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT HIGH QUALITY
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
YOUNG CHILDREN WITH THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND COGNITIVE
COGNITIVE SKILLS THEY NEED TO BE
READY TO ENTER KINDERGARTEN AND
HAVE A BRIGHT FUTURE.
FURTHERMORE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMMING
PARTICULARLY CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY SUPPORT.
TO OUR STATES WORKING FAMILIES.
HOWEVER FOR MANY FAMILIES FOR
MANY WORKING FAMILIES CHILD CARE
IS INACCESSIBLE DIFFICULT TO
FIND OR SIMPLY TOO EXPENSIVE.
CALIFORNIA FACES A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF CHILD CARE LOW
INCOME.
WORKING FAMILIES ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS SHORTAGE THE MOST.
RECENT DATA INDICATES AT ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION CHILDREN ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE.
BUT DO NOT RECEIVE IT DUE TO THE
LACK OF ACCESS IN THE STATE.
THAT MEANS EIGHT OUT OF NINE
CHILDREN WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE ARE NOT
RECEIVING IT.
WELL I COMMEND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET.
WHICH PROVIDES PLENTY OF
INVESTMENTS FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE EXISTING
PROPOSAL.
EVEN CHILD CARE OUT OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION INVESTMENT
AND EXPANSION WILL MEAN THAT THE
LOWEST INCOME WORKING FAMILIES
WILL STILL NOT BENEFIT FROM
EXISTING AND PROPOSED STATE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS AREA.
THAT'S WHY I STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE. TO PROVE AB.
ONE NINETY FOUR WITH ME TODAY TO
DISCUSS THIS FURTHER FROM SAN
BERNARDINO.
IS JAMES MOST AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER
ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO ALSO
WELCOME MERRY IGNATIUS A BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION.
MEMBER AND REPRESENTATIVE OF
PARENTS VOICES.
WHAT THANK YOU ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ALLOW ME TO BE HERE
AND ENSURE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL MY NAME'S JAMES MOSES
I'M SAN MARINO COUNTY REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR CHILDCARE RESOURCE
CENTER?
WE SERVE APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN EACH MONTH IN
SAN MARINO IN NORTHERN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
AND WE ALL IN ADDITION TO MANY
THINGS WE OPERATED ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS ONE OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD -- BE A
RECIPIENT OF THIS FUNDING TO
BENEFIT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES SO
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED --
YOU KNOW ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
CHILDREN ARE ELIGIBLE BUT NOT
RECEIVING SERVICES ONLY ONE IN
NINE CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE
ARE RECEIVING CHURCH -- SERVICES
IN ONLY ONE ELEVEN INFANTS AND
TODDLERS RECEIVE SERVICES IN
SEMINOLE COUNTY OUR NEEDS MUCH
GREATER WE HAVE -- NEARLY 30% OF
ALL OF OUR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN LIVE IN POVERTY IN IN
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
NUMBER RISES 240% OF FAMILIES
LIVING IN CHURCH -- POVERTY.
FURTHERMORE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DIDN'T PROVIDE ANY
FUNDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
FOR ADDITIONAL SPACES SO THAT'S
A CONCERN OF THIS IS FOR US AS
WELL THIS BILL WILL -- PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES FOR ADDITIONAL
CHILDREN THAT ARE THAT ARE SO WE
NEED -- ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF
THIS PROGRAM THE MONEY GOING TO
GENERAL CHILD CARE IN
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS
THESE ARE THE PRIMARY SOURCE
PROGRAMS FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN INFANTS. ZERO TO THREE
TO PROVIDE IN FIND -- INFANT AND
TODDLER CHILD CARE WHICH IS NOT
ONLY THE MOST EXPENSIVE CHILD
CARE TO FIND BUT IT'S ALSO THE
HARDEST CHILD CARE TO FIND.
SO WE REALLY ARE HOPING THAT YOU
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT THIS BILL --
CONSIDER WITH AN AYE VOTE THIS
IS AN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ISSUE
AND WE'VE HEARD LOTS OF THERE'S
LOTS OF INFORMATION ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF EARLY LEARNING
EXPERIENCES.
BOTH THE IMMEDIATE RETURN IN THE
LONG TERM A RETURN ON INVESTMENT
SO WE REALLY ASK YOU TO CONSIDER --
THE BENEFIT THAT THIS WILL MAKE
AS A STARTING POINT TO HELP
FAMILIES ACHIEVE SELF
SUFFICIENCY IN BEGIN -- ALIVE
TOWARD PROSPERITY SUING COURAGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MERRY EGNATIUS I'M THE STATE
RIGHT ORGANIZER FOR PARENT
VOICES -- WE JUST TRULY BELIEVE
THAT THE WELL BEING OF CHILDREN
IS INTRINSICALLY LINKED TO THE
WELL BEING OF THEIR PARENTS--
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS NOW WE'VE
BEEN BRINGING MOTHERS WHO ARE ON
THE WAITING LIST TO THE CAPITAL
TO SHARE THEIR STORIES THEY POUR
THEIR HEART OUT THEY DESCRIBE
THE CHALLENGES OF THE SACRIFICES.
AND YET YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR ON THERE HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THIS
PROGRAM.
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FOR REALLY SHEDDING A
LIGHT ON THIS CRISIS IN USING
HER PLATFORM.
TO BE ABLE TO BRING THE STORIES
TO LIFE.
THE BEAUTY OF THIS BILL IS THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY WHAT PARENTS WANT
AND NEED.
THIS BILL TAKES US AWAY
OFTENTIMES IN THIS BUILDING WE
ARE TARGET POLICIES TOWARDS AGE
GROUP OR WE TARGET POLICIES BY
SAUDI.
AND THAT'S NOT HOW FAMILIES
OPERATE -- WE NEED CARE FOR OUR
CHILDREN FROM BIRTH ONWARDS --
WE CAN'T PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH
CHILD GETS CARE ON BECAUSE WE'RE
ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE TO BE THE
ONE THAT STAYS HOME WITH THE
OTHER ONE RIGHT WE WE THE WHOLE
FAMILY.
NEEDS TO PROGRESS FORWARD AND
THE OTHER TRUTH IS THAT FAMILIES
USE ALL TYPE OF SETTINGS AT ALL
DIFFERENT POINTS IN THEIR
CHILD'S LIFE I'VE USED FAMILY
FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR CARE FAMILY
CHILDCARE CENTER BASED CARE.
AND WAS BASED ON MY CHILD'S
NEEDS AT THAT PARTICULAR MOMENT
AND SO WE DON'T NEED A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AND AND
THIS BILL REALLY ALLOWS FAMILIES
TO MAKE CHOICES.
THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER THEIR
SCHEDULE THEY DON'T HAVE CONTROL
OVER A LOT OF THINGS IN LIFE.
FLEXIBLE CHILDCARE OPTIONS GIVE
THEM THAT ONE SENSE OF CONTROL
TO CHOOSE WHAT WORKS BEST FOR
THEM AND THAT'S WHY THEY NEED
THAT FLEXIBILITY -- YOU KNOW
IT'S ALSO I WAS THINKING ABOUT
IT IN HEALTHCARE WE DON'T --
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO JUST
BABIES FOR PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
TO JUST FOUR YEAR OLDS OR HEALTH
CARE TO JUST SCHOOL AGE KIDS WE
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO THE WHOLE
FAMILY.
AND WE NEED TO APPLY THAT SAME
THING -- TO CHILDCARE WE ALSO
BELIEVE THIS IS A RACIAL GENDER
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE BILL 86% OF
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE WAITING FOR
CHILD CARE OUR CHILDREN OF COLOR.
THEY WERE BLACK MOMS AND OPENED
LAST NIGHT SLEEPING IN CARS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET TO WORK
THEY CAN'T PAY FOR CHILDCARE AND
THERE THEY ARE HOMELESS AND SO
WE WE REALLY NEED.
TO UNDERSTAND AN UNDERSCORE HOW
THESE HOW THIS BILL REALLY
ADDRESSES -- INEQUITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEE BYNUM ASK ME --
THIRTY AND THIRTY TWO W. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MACKENZIE
CHRISTIANSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI DONNA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MOMS RAISING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DONNA STARED DROWNED BEHALF OF
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
WE'RE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JENNIFER CRAPPIE WITH PARA
PLACES CALIFORNIA AND ARE
FIFTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND I WAS ASKED BY THE CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER ALSO A SPONSOR OF
THE BILL -- TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
JUST LOOK AT THE OTHER WITH THE
CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT. TO BE
TERRACE TRIAL THREE SIXTY LOS
ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT.
JACKIE LONG WITH GRACE AND HELP
ALREADY CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF
RESPECT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JUSTIN ARE PUTTING WITH EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHERINE OCCURRED ON ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE LA IN SUPPORT. TO
THE AND THEN IF ANA CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT.
ON A HAS A BED WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CATION SAY WE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE RESOURCE
REFERRAL NETWORK A SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
I KNOW YOU COMMITTEES WITH EARLY
AGE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- IT MUST
THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FOR FOR THIS -- YOU CAN TELL
FROM THE TESTIMONY PROVIDED BY
OUR WITNESSES HOW IMPORTANT THE
ISSUE IS -- FOR FROM DECEMBER
DINO COUNTY I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE COME THIS
DISTANCE TO BE HERE.
AND MS IGNATIUS REPRESENTING THE
PARENTS VOICES EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND I'M SO PROUD THAT
YOU ARE HERE -- BUT ALSO AS A
MEMBER OF THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A MOTION AND THEN DENY MOVING
YOU.
AND WHEN YOU CAN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RANTS HI RES I AM
MATHIS [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIVES AND I AM MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
THE THREE ZERO WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OF THANK YOU.
YOU.
THE LAST OFFER. FOR MORE.
I HAVE ONE OTHER BILL
[inaudible]
SECOND.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MISTER GIBSON.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL.
I DO ACCEPT [inaudible]
AMENDMENTS.
WE WANT TO EXPAND TRAINING FOR
OUR FOSTER YOUTH RESOURCE
FAMILIES TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION AND LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND MAKING SURE THAT OUR FOSTER
FAMILIES ARE AWARE OF THIS SO
THAT THEY CAN SEE THE SIGNS AND
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES FOR FOSTER
USE.
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S WHY WE'VE INTRODUCED THIS
LEGISLATION WITH ME TODAY.
I HAVE. TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THIS BILL JOSEPHINE THEME STIR
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASE
MANAGER AT WE'VE AND JULIE
MCCORMICK WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE FELLOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR VICE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU TEACHER AND ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER RAY IS -- FOR AUTHORING
AB.-EIGHT SIXTY FIVE I AM JOSEPHINE
FILM STIR.
AND I AM A SURVIVOR OF
EXPLOITATION AS WELL AS A
NATIONAL.
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT -- I AM
ALSO.
A CASE MANAGER FOR A LOCAL RAPE
CRISIS CENTER HERE LOCALLY.
WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT --
SURVIVORS IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WE ALSO PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN RESPONSE IN OUTREACH
SERVICES. TO VICTIMS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING.
I AM HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
AS AN ADVOCATE I HAVE WORKED
DIRECTLY WITH FOSTER CARE YOUTH
WHO WERE TRAFFICKED.
THESE YOUTH ARE OFTEN VULNERABLE
TO TRAFFICKING JUST AS A RESULT
OF BEING IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM.
YOU'VE THE HAVE EXPERIENCED
ABUSE AND NEGLECT ARE OFTEN
SEARCHING FOR LOVE AND
ACCEPTANCE IN AND CAN FIND
THEMSELVES IN SCARY AND
SOMETIMES DEADLY SITUATIONS.
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
I HAVE SEEN YOUTH PLACE WITH
FOSTER PARENTS ALTHOUGH DOING
THEIR BEST.
HAD NO IDEA ABOUT TRAFFICKING IN
THE WAYS TO SUPPORT.
TRAFFIC OR AT RISK YOUTH.
THIS RESULTED IN MANY FOSTER
YOUTH LEAVING THEIR HOMES AND
RETURNING TO THEIR TRAFFICKERS.
HOWEVER THIS WOULD BE DIFFERENT
IF THESE FOSTER FAMILIES.
WE'RE TRAINED TO RECOGNIZE
TRAFFICKING DYNAMICS AND
VULNERABILITIES AND PROVIDED THE
TOOLS TO ASSIST THESE CHILDREN
IN TURNING.
IN TURN PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
SAFE PLACE TO RECOVER THRIVE IN
HE'LL.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT ALL FOSTER
FAMILIES WE PROPERLY TRAINED
WHEN PROVIDING CARE TO FOSTER
YOUTH.
WITH AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION FOSTER FAMILIES
WILL BE BETTER EQUIPPED TO
IDENTIFY THE SIGNS.
OF TRAFFICKING AND THE
RECRUITMENT TACTICS WHICH COULD
POTENTIALLY PREVENT A CHILD FROM
BEING TRAFFICKED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AB EIGHT SIX FIVE WOULD GIVE
RESOURCE FAMILIES THE ESSENTIAL
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN SAFE FROM
HARMFUL TRAUMA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHAT ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE?
TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. ONE OTHER WITNESSES SO
THERE'S ANOTHER WITNESS.
I'M SORRY.
SHOULD BE BRIEF I'LL BE BRIEF --
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR RAZ FOR AUTHORING AB.
EIGHT SIX FIVE I'M JULIE
MCCORMICK ITS STATE FELL A
FELLOW OF THE WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE I'M HERE TODAY AS A
SPONSOR OF AV -- EIGHT SIX FIVE
I BELIEVE OUR OTHER WITNESS
JOSEPHINE TEAMSTER OUT REALLY
COVERED EVERYTHING BUT JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE THINGS --
FOSTER CARE FAMILIES ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE INNER MONOMERS
CRITICAL PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHO ARE IN A POSITION TO
IDENTIFY AND EXPLOIT A YOUNG
PERSON EARLY ON AND GET THEM THE
HELP THEY NEED -- AS OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
RESOURCE FAMILIES TO BE TRAINED
HOWEVER AB EIGHT SIX FIVE WILL
ADDRESS A GAP IN TRAINING AND
THAT THE ISSUE OF TRAFFIC AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY COMMERCIAL AND
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED.
CHILDREN -- THAT TRAINING IS
CURRENTLY OPTIONAL SO WHEN
EXPLOITED CHILDREN ARE PLACED IN
HOMES OF THE FOSTER PARENT WHO
UNDERSTANDS THEIR NEEDS AND THE
TRAUMA AND IS FOCUSED ON THEIR
SAFETY.
THE RESULTS IN THE CHILD BE MORE
RECEPTIVE TO SERVICES AND
INCREASES THE CHANCE THEY WILL
AVOID FURTHER EXPLOITATION.
I'M FOR THESE REASONS AND FOR
WHAT JOSEPHINE IS ALREADY TOLD
US THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
EIGHT SIX FIVE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE I ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU THEIR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
HI FILES AND ON BEHALF OF PEACE
WERE BY THEN STAND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK.
HI MY NAME IS SLEEPING IN MY
COMMUNITY -- MEMBER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS AS WELL.
HELLO JASMINE AMOS NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE ODESSA BERRY POWERS WITH THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEE NOT BRING IT BACK TO
SEE THE COMMITTEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY WE HAVE A AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE BEFORE WE TAKE A
VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND [inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES I REYES III
MATHIS.
MATHIS I'D BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON.
GIPSON I'D MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
MICHAEL AND GIVE [inaudible]
ALONG.
WE WE CAN.
OKAY LET'S GO BACK.
TO OPEN ROLE ON CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
LOTUS FORTY ZERO BERMAN.
CHOI HI TôI I A FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I A MAIENSCHEIN.
KERN WROTE.
SIXTY ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AB.
SIX FILE ITEM ONE A. B. SIX THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TO ZERO
MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN.
CHOI.
CHOI AYE GIPSON.
GETS IN I AM MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE I CURRENT WROTE.
SIX TO ZERO ALL RIGHT AND THREE
FROM.
FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE SIXTY
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTERS TO TO
ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN [inaudible]
CHOI.
CHOI I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE I CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TWO ZERO BUT FOR FILE ITEM
FOR AB ONE NINETY FOUR CURRENT
VOTERS THREE TO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM BERMAN.
CHOI.
CHOI I MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
STONE I KERN WROTE.
SIX ZERO FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY
THREE NINETY FIVE THE CURRENT
VOTERS TO TO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN.
CHOI HI CHOI I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE AYE AYE CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY TWO THE
CURRENT VOTERS TO TO TO ZERO
MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN.
CHOI.
CHOI ARI FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
STONE I CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT CURRENT
VOTERS TO DO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN.
CHOI HI CHOI I FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
I MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE I CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
EIGHT THIRTEEN CURRENT VOTERS TO
TO ZERO MATHIS MATHIS I BERMAN.
CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
AND I MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE I CURRENT VOTE. SIX
TWO ZERO FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB.
SIX SIX I'M SORRY FILE ITEM
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
THE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TO ZERO
BERMAN.
I CHOI.
HI CHOI I MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
AB WHAT. ONE ZERO SIX EIGHT THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO ZERO
MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN BERMAN I ENJOY.
CHOI HI FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT RENT IS.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE AB ELEVEN NINETY NINE THE
CURRENT LOTUS TWO TO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN BERMAN I ENJOY.
CHOI I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
STONE.
STONE I CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN AB ONE TWO TWO NINE THE
CURRENT VOTERS TO TO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM BERMAN.
BERMAN I ENJOY CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HIGH MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE I KERN VOTE.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR THE
CURRENT VOTE IS [inaudible]
THREE TO ZERO MATHIS.
I'M SORRY FILE ITEM THIRTY AB
ONE THREE TWO FOUR CURRENT
VOTERS.
THREE TO ZERO MATHIS NOW BERMAN.
BERMAN I ENJOY.
NOW FOR CHOI NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE.
FIVE TO ONE FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
AB.
ONE FOUR ZERO THREE CURRENT READ
AS THREE TO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO BERMAN.
BERMAN I ENJOY.
TRY NOT VOTING WAS ONE OF FOR
PERSONAL.
THREE NO NO.
SO I KNOW.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE [inaudible]
FIVE TO TWO CAN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR CURRENT BUT
IS FIVE TWO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I AM FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I AM MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE.
KERN VOTE.
EIGHT ZERO THIS IS A BERMAN.
GOING HI PHIL.
ACCORDING TO THE WE WERE TALKING.
ON THE CONSENT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
THAT IS SIX TWO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO AND SAID THIS OUT
FILE ITEM ONE AB SIX CURRENT
VOTED SIX TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM THREE AB
ONE SIXTY TWO CURRENT VOTED SIX
TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I'VE VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM FOR AB
ONE NINETY FOUR CURRENT VOTED
SIX TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM MISTER
DOCTOR CHORE.
HE KNOWS WE HAVE WITH.
FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY THREE
NINETY FIVE CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN HIGH MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
FOR FIFTY TWO CURRENT VOTED SIX
TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I AM MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TWO ZERO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
AB EIGHT THIRTEEN CURRENT VOTED
SIX TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT ZERO FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE CURRENT VOTER
SEVEN TO ZERO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I AM FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR A. B. TEN SIXTY EIGHT
CURRENT THAT IS SEVEN TWO ZERO
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE AB ELEVEN NINETY NINE
CURRENT VOTER SEVEN TO ZERO
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
CURRENT VOTER SEVEN TO ZERO
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I A FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TWO ZERO FILE ITEM THIRTY
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR CURRENT
VOTE.
FIVE TO ONE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
SIX TO ONE FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
AB FORTINO THREE CURRENT VOTE IS.
FIVE TWO ZERO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO I'M SORRY.
SIX TO TWO FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE A. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO WE'RE WAITING FOR
THE PRESENTATION OF THE LAST TO
BILL.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
ON ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
ONE TWENTY FIVE HE WILL BE HERE
SHORTLY
.
IS THERE A WITNESS HERE --
MISTER MCCARTY SPILL.
YES.
MR BURKE MISTER BERMAN WILL
PRESENT TIME.
OKAY. TEN ROOMS CONVERSAR
[inaudible]
EVEN BETTER [inaudible]
ON THE MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE THE SOMETHING OVER
MCCARTY AB ONE TWENTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES A SINGLE REGIONALI
STATE REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM
FOR CHILDCARE PRESCHOOL.
AND EARLY LEARNING SERVICES
CURRENTLY OUR RATE POLICIES
BIFURCATED BETWEEN TWO SYSTEMS
REGIONAL MARKET RATE WHICH PAY
CERTAIN PROVIDERS BASED ON A
PERCENTILE OF THE COST OF
PROVIDING CARE IN THAT REGION.
IN STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
WHICH PAYS PROVIDERS AN
ARBITRARY AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR
CHILD AND IS LOWER THAN THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE.
IN THE LAST FOUR BUDGET YEARS
THE STATE IS INCREASED LOTS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM GENERAL CHILD CARE IN
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM.
AS A WAY TO ATTEMPT TO KEEP UP
WITH THE RISING COST OF DOING
BUSINESS IS AN EARLY LEARNING
PROVIDER THE STATE IS INCREASE
THE ARMAR FOUR TIMES SINCE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN DEMONSTRATING
THAT WE ARE NOT DOING NEARLY
ENOUGH TO PAY OUR PROVIDERS
ADEQUATELY IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
SLOTS VIABLE THE STATE HAS TO
PAY PROVIDERS AND TEACHERS
BETTER.
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS AND EARLY
LEARNING TEACHERS ARE
CONSISTENTLY AND WOEFULLY
UNDERPAID AND AB ONE TWENTY FIVE
WILL FIX THAT THROUGH A SINGLE
REGIONAL AS REIMBURSEMENT RATES
SYSTEM WITH ME TODAY IS DONNA
SNEER INJURE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER.
AND ERIN GABLE AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR EXTERNAL IN GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS OFFICE FOR
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
AND WOULD ESPECIALLY LIKE THIS
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
STAFF FOR THE PHENOMENAL TALKING
POINTS.
IF AND THEY DID SUCH A GOOD JOB
COVERING AND A GOOD FOR WHAT IT
IS LIKE.
I MY NAME'S DONNA SNARE INJURE
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AT THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER AND I
WAS ALSO PROUD TO CO CHAIR.
AN EIGHTEEN MONTH LONG
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT PUT
TOGETHER THE TOP OF THE PROPOSAL
IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY.
I'M I THINK THAT IN THE TALKING
POINTS TO COVER THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A BIFURCATED SYSTEM THAT
COMES OUT OF THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY A HUNDRED
YEAR HISTORY.
OF PROVIDING CHILD CARE AND OUT
OF THAT WE HAVE HAD FITS AND
STARTS OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO UNIFY.
AND WE SEE THIS BILL AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING A COMPLEX
SYSTEM TOGETHER INTO A SINGLE
REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE.
THAT PROVIDES THE COMPENSATION
SYSTEM THAT'S BASED ON THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PROVIDER.
AND BUILDS MORE UNITY AMONGST
THE SYSTEM IT'S TRANSPARENT IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR ALL OF YOU
WHEN YOU INVEST IN THE IN THE
PROGRAM.
AND I'M GONNA LET AARON GABLE
TALK ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF THE
PROPOSAL AND WE'RE DOING OUR
CONDENSED VERSION.
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
HEARING GAVE ON THE HOT THE
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA YOUR STATE
COMMISSION EARLY CHILDHOOD AND I
WE JUST WANT TO EXPRESS HOW
EXCITED WE ARE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN AB ONE TWENTY FIVE
WHICH PROPOSES THIS SINGLE
REGIONALI STATE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE SYSTEM FOR CHILD CARE.
PRESCHOOL AND ALL EARLY LEARNING
SERVICES THAT ONE COMPENSATES
ALL TEACHERS AND PROVIDERS FOR
THE TRUE COST OF PROVIDING CARE.
NUMBER TWO RECOGNIZES THE COSTS
FOR MEETING EXISTING BUT VARYING
QUALITY STANDARDS INTENDED TO
DRIVE CHILD OUTCOMES OF THIS
LARGE INVESTMENT WE HAVE IN OUR
CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
AND THREE STABILIZES THE ABILITY
OF OUR STATES MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING OPTIONS WE CALL IT THE
CHILD CARE STABILIZATION FORMULA.
YOU HAVE THREE GRAPHICS IN FRONT
OF YOU THAT ARE INTENDED TO VERY
QUICKLY AND GRAPHICALLY
EXPLAINED VERY COMPLICATED --
PROPOSAL THE OF A WONDERFUL
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON THIS
SINGLE REGIONALI STATE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM FOR EARLY
CARE WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT THE
EARLY THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
MAINTAINED -- AND INCLUDING ITS
VARIOUS PROGRAM MISSIONS WHICH
HAVE BEEN -- CAN YOU.
DID YOU TO ACHIEVE THE VARIOUS
PROGRAM MISSIONS WE HAVE THAT
NEED TO BE FUNDED ADEQUATELY IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE THEIR MISSIONS
AND THEIR SHARED MISSION.
OF SUPPORTING WORKING FAMILIES
AND THRIVING CHILDREN.
I MEAN SIGNIFICANTLY WE BELIEVE
THAT LIKE WITH OUR OB LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA THAT WE
HAVE FOR OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM WE
CAN HAVE A FORMULA FOR CHILD
CARE FUNDING THAT IS A DRIVER
FOR THE CHILD AND THE SYSTEM
OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT TO RATHER
THAN THIS KIND BIFURCATED.
MESS THAT WE HAVE SO THE FIRST
GRAPHIC SHOWS YOU THE BIFURCATED
SYSTEM.
THE SECOND GRAPHIC IS A
DEPICTION OF THE CONCEPT WHICH
IS QUITE SIMPLY.
TAKING A REVISED REGIONAL MARKET
RATE SYSTEM IN TRYING TO CORRECT
SOME THE MARKET FAILURES THEY'RE
BUILT INTO THE SYSTEM.
AND THEN ADDING ON TO IT --
EIGHT QUALITY ADJUSTMENT FACTOR
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ASKED TO MEET HIGHER STANDARDS
AND REQUIREMENTS -- MOST LARGELY
IN TERMS OF DRIVING THEIR COSTS
IS THE CHANGE IN THE CHILD ADULT
RATIO.
SO -- WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME ALSO -- CREATING A THE
ABILITY -- FOR INCENTIVES FOR
TELL TWENTY TWO PROGRAMS TO ALSO
MEET TITLE FIVE STANDARDS IF
THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO WE WILL SEE
THAT THE BILL ALSO CONTAINS A
PILOT. FOR THAT RECOMMENDATION.
SO THE THIRD GRAPHIC YOU HAVE
THEN EXPLAINS IMPLEMENTATION
DESIGN OF OUR PROPOSAL.
RATHER THAN TO EXPECT THE STATE
TO ABSORB ALL THE COSTS OF THIS
ALIGNMENT IN ONE YEAR LIKE WITH
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA IT'S A METHODOLOGYFOR
HAVING THE STATE CREEK TARGETS
FOR REACHING THIS NEW SINGLE
RATE SYSTEM.
AND THEN OVER TIME IN EACH
BUDGET ACT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR WILL BE ABLE TO DECIDE
HOW MUCH MONEY THEY HAVE TO
CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS THESE NEW
TARGETS.
SO -- WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
VERY PRUDENT BUT CRUCIAL CHANGE
THE DRIVER IN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM OUR FUNDING.
AND WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HAVE A QUESTION ON YOUR LAST
CHART.
YES THIS IS THE AMOUNT THE
COUNTY WOULD HAVE TO PAY.
NO THIS IS THE AMOUNT THAT THE
STATE WOULD PAY TO THE TO THE
CONTRACTORS HER PROVIDING CHILD
CARE SERVICES.
SO SAN FRANCISCO WOULD RECEIVE.
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND SAN
BERNADINE -- ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THE COSTS OF THE MARKET SO WHAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS BASED ON IS
USING THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE
SURVEY WHICH IS CONDUCTED.
EVERY TWO YEARS.
AND IT ASSESSES THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS IN ANY GIVEN AREA.
SO YOU'RE HIGHER COST
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW ALL ARE
NOT COMPENSATED BASED ON THAT SO
THIS WITH A JUST FOR THAT.
SO EVERYBODY GETS AN INCREASE
BUT THE HIGH COST COUNTIES
INCREASE ESCALATES A BIT MORE.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HI THERE MY NAME IS PATRICK MORE
TEAR WITH FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN
KIDS REPRESENTING OVER -- THREE
HUNDRED PLEASE SHE SERVICE
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE
STATE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND I AM COMMITTEES WITH EARLY
AGE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI TIM FITZHARRIS CHILD THREE
SIXTY LOS ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN ARE PUTTING WITH EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THREE YOU'RE GONNA ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE LA IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOES THE GET A WHAT THE CHILD
CARE LINES OF LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DONNA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MOMS RAISING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENDON TOOK ON BEHALF OF KIDDING
GO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EARLY
LEARNING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JACKIE ONE WITH GRACE AND HELP
HIRING CALIFORNIANS WRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATION VERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDCARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MOLLY BYNUM UW ASK ME LOCAL
THEIR NINE THIRTY ON BEHALF OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND THIRTY
NINE COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NOT A BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE YES MISTER MATHIS.
ASSEMBLYMAN DEVON MATHIS ALSO IN
SUPPORT -- WOULD LOVE TO JOIN ON
AS JOINT AUTHOR WITH YOU TO SHOW
BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS IS
EXPRESSLY IS IS BECAUSE OF THE
SENATE.
IF YOU'LL HAVE ME ON IT YEAH
MADE MY DAY ALL RIGHT.
CAN THE OTHER CO AUTHORS OF
JOINT AUTHORS.
ALL RIGHT -- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SECOND BY
MISTER MATHIS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BY THE BERMAN DID A GREAT JOB.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT THIS IS PART
OF OUR OF OUR PRE K. FOR ALL
PACKAGE THERE'S THREE BILLS.
AND THIS REALLY IS THE GLUE THAT
HOLDS IT TOGETHER BECAUSE ONE IS
ABOUT SLOTS ONCE FACILITIES THIS
IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THE
PROGRAMS.
ARE FINANCIALLY VIABLE WE INVEST
IN THE WORK FORCE AND WE FOCUS
ON QUALITY JUST. TWO WEEKS AGO
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO SCHOOL
DISTRICT SHUT DOWN A THIRD OF
THEIR PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THESE
FAMILIES.
DON THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
ANYMORE IN LARGE PART BECAUSE WE
DON'T PROPERLY REIMBURSED FROM
THE STATE CRIME CONTRACTED YOU
SEE PROGRAM SO THIS BILL WILL
ADDRESS THIS EXACT ISSUE.
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ECONOMICALLY VIABLE
SO WITH THAT ASK YOUR EYE.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE TAKE THE ROOM.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
RIGHT YES HI RES I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS I BERMAN BERMAN I CHOI
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
STONE.
STONE I SIX TWO ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
I'LL BE REALLY GOOD FOR ANYTHING.
YES THEY CLOSED TODAY
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
MR BERMAN.
IF I'M EVER LET YOU CAN PERCENT
I THREE WE WILL LEAVE THE RECORD
OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES. FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS FIVE MINUTES
.
FILE ITEM TO AB.
ONE TWENTY FIVE THE CURRENT META
SIX ZERO GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE
KERN VOTE
.
SEVEN TO ZERO HE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED